This episode of Your Mom's house is brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress,
the only online mattress company that provides free delivery setup and mattress
removal.
Christina,
what it do
you know what I mean?
I like this music.
I like it too.
Wow.
I like that.
Oh,
Catatonia by Canon.
Canon C.
A.
N.
I like it.
Where are you going to be next,
Jean?
Well,
Jean,
I'm going to be February 23rd at West Siloam springs,
Oklahoma at the Cherokee casino.
February 28th through March 2nd Madison West.
Come on Ya.
At the comedy club on state tickets are moving very quickly for that.
The belly filling up fast.
April four through six mini apple tits,
Minnesota at the acme comedy club.
May 10th and 11th Tempe,
Arizona at the Tampon Improv.
May 34 through June 1st Burbank,
a sperm bank,
California at the flood pairs comedy club.
And then June 20th through 22nd Washington deck come at the deck come.
And probably also I've got some other stuff coming up.
I'm going to be looking at U Chicago.
I'm going to be looking at you Boston.
Um,
so stay tuned for those days.
So those will be in the summer sometime.
Tickets at Christina P on line.
Gene
here is a big update for me.
This is crazy.
Okay.
Uh,
May 5th,
our fifth.
I am adding my fifth show at the Moore Theater in Seattle,
Washington.
All right.
Um,
that's on sale.
Uh,
June 28th,
I'm adding my second show at the Orpheum theater in Wichita,
Kansas.
That goes on sale at 10:00 AM local time is Wednesday.
And we also added a second show in Hampton Beach,
New Hampshire.
That is August 10.
So those are the summer bro.
Yeah,
those are the new,
the add ons.
And then I can tell you an update as far as the,
uh,
tickets situations for some of these shows.
Uh,
this week there's some single tickets left.
That's it in um,
late Pittsburgh and like less than a hundred you'd be sitting alone.
But in Cincinnati as well,
um,
you can still get tickets on March 9th to the hard rock in Hollywood,
Florida.
You
can get tickets.
Uh,
March 26 it's mark to March 26th.
It's march 26.
Stupid.
I know he fucked that up.
Really?
Uh,
that's,
I'm in Portland.
Maine.
Late show has been added in new haven,
Connecticut.
It's March 30th,
Connecticut and then the late shows in Madison and Milwaukee.
That's April 11 and 12.
They have tickets.
The early shows are sold out.
You could also try to get tickets to the late show in Nashville,
Tennessee.
April 14th and there is a late show,
April 28th in Medford at the [inaudible] theater.
Those are all my updates.
Tom segura.com go to the tour page.
Uh,
genes are at your tickets are our to tell Christina p online.
There you go.
You see the shirt I'm wearing?
Yeah.
You're wearing a sub cane shirts in my closet.
Dude.
Had to,
I was so excited that I found I barely fit into it,
but that's that.
Oh Gee shirt.
That's uh,
that's what he was talking about.
I squeeze like one then that really I did it to,
that one blew up,
man.
That was a big shirt.
Limited edition.
This is the little bit,
that was so fun.
I keep thinking about what a charming gentleman he was.
Yeah,
it was great,
man.
It was so exciting to see you.
So stoked.
That's what everybody kept messaging me and they're like,
I've never seen you so happy.
I know.
And it's funny because we stopped rolling and we were taking photos with him and
you are just ear to ear.
And I said to him,
I was like,
listen,
birth of the children didn't matter.
This was Tommy's prom.
That's what you said.
It's a big daddy Kane.
You're like,
this is Tom's prom eating you.
So excited.
He was like,
okay.
All right,
you guys are dorks.
Alright,
Weirdos.
Uh,
Jane,
there's a lot to get into.
We have amazing guests today.
It's going to be a lot of fun.
Why don't we go ahead and kick the park?
Oh boy,
this guy looks interesting.
Let's start
put,
there's some woman are women out there
who really like,
um,
having their push his luck.
Oh,
I knew it.
I know,
I know.
[inaudible]
yeah.
Hey man,
how did I know?
I remember.
I was like,
what's the opening club?
Is it going to be pussies?
Dick Fart.
And it was exactly what you weren't.
It was a super cool guy.
Uh,
can we see that again?
I want to see his very first clip.
I just told,
oh,
I don't like his voice.
Um,
that there's some woman are women out there
who've really like,
um,
having their pussies.
That is a cool guy.
I think a lot of women like cool guy.
I think a louder,
should that be louder?
Yes.
He says this.
Good.
Okay.
A lot of women like getting their policies.
Look,
it's really,
you could raise it up a little bit.
Oh,
okay.
It's really matter of whose licking it.
Why can't I just indiscriminate liquors.
It's gotta be like,
I wasn't buddy.
You want to put their mouth on your style.
Does it matter who puts their mouth on you?
Does it not matter for you?
No,
of course not.
I go when,
when you're out on the road and you're cool.
Beaver bus,
the bang bus,
the bang bus allows anyone who's down to bang on it.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
Cool.
I don't have any,
there's no rules.
There's no rules on the bang.
I don't know.
Are you down?
Do you want to bang?
You got a mouse?
I can put stuff in.
I cannot believe that somebody has standards for a mouth.
I mean I understand.
Are you serious?
I understand the vagina.
Okay.
Like you know it's like,
yeah,
you're not just going to f whoever,
but if someone's like put your stuff on my mouth.
I don't care.
Put your stuff in my mouth.
Yeah,
there's no like standard for that.
What do you mean?
I'm sorry,
I don't understand what I'm saying.
Like any woman who was like,
do you want to put your stuff in my mouth?
I'd be like,
okay,
but what about the woman with no teeth or letter?
The moose soup lady probably like sores on her mouth.
It doesn't bother you.
It doors.
I mean now you're starting to talk about something that you visually can see as
a problem.
But like if somebody who's just like,
you know,
undesired unattractive,
I'd be like,
yeah,
you can still put it in her mouth.
I guess that's true.
Cause like lot lizards
people heard of though,
where you think we sleep on the row,
we port render the bus lives in the lot.
Lot Lizards.
They're like nasty checks.
It's like decks,
right?
Yeah.
They just hide in the bushes.
And we were like,
Eh,
no,
I get it.
A little sucky.
Done.
Yeah.
And how much do you have to pay the lot lizard.
No Lot losers live on it.
That's how they live.
If they live on coffee.
Yeah.
It's like a calm dog.
Uh,
you know El Chapo?
I know,
I know him.
El Chapo,
they just,
so he's on it.
He's an having a trial right now in Brooklyn for a,
just a lot of crimes,
let's say conspiracies and murder and trafficking.
And somebody testified that they would procure underage prostitutes for him.
Um,
and he was getting like young teens and that he said that they were that money
when he had sex with them,
that they were vitamins for life.
That's pretty out there.
I mean,
it's not that out there for him.
I feel like a lot of guys believe that.
Like my dad.
I think that
the guitar riff gets married,
but don't you think that there's a lot of older men gentlemen out there that
feel like Young Pussy is a fountain of Youth?
Well yeah,
they're not wrong.
I'm saying that,
but you get the vitamins in your painter.
I think able to being able to categorize it and describe it as vitamin.
It's very articulate and crayons and really out there and accurate too.
It is accurate but I just,
you know,
usually when you hear it spoken you go,
oh wow.
Hearing it is different.
You're like,
I always knew it took place.
Yeah.
That description really sticks with you,
that description and also,
cause you and I are really ended the show love after a lockup.
Oh my God.
So into it and there's a guy on there who's married to one girl.
They have one two year old and then they have another baby on the way.
She's pregnant,
he's married to her and then now he's in love with another girl and he's going
to propose to the other girl.
Women are both unaware of the other ones.
It's pretty definitive.
It's just out of prison.
So he's on parole.
Like the guy doesn't have a job,
he has nothing lined up and he is thrill is to be a liar face to these two
women's pretty scary actually.
It is probably the scariest guy.
They don't tell you what he,
what he was locked up for.
Well they say it's a parole violation,
but you don't know what the original crime was.
But that,
that dude is the scariest by far of everybody.
He enjoys the attention of like,
baby,
I got to go now and that girl's crying.
Stop,
stop,
stop crying,
crying.
He is dead.
And He um,
he toys with them.
He's like real master manipulator.
Narcissi scary.
Yeah,
he's kind of,
Ooh,
that's so scary.
I know,
but the show is unbelievable.
Here's some advice.
By the way,
this is what I got from watching that show.
Uh,
don't reach out to convicts.
They're terrible people.
Not all of them don't start dating while in prison.
That's what the show,
that's the lesson of the show or don't try to marry them and try to get them to
be normal people.
Well,
it happens.
Everybody is like,
they're all the same.
The ones who reach out like they want love,
you can tell that they're like,
they want love,
right.
That's what they want are the ones who are,
who are reaching out to the,
to the prisoners.
They go on these sites and then they find somebody who's like confined to a
space and you go like,
well that's this person can't hurt me.
It's ideal.
They can't leave me,
they can't cheat on me.
They can't do these,
you know,
and they,
and they also rely on me for my affection to my attention.
You see it,
you see it all,
it's a good dynamic.
And then like they build the relationship under those,
you know,
uh,
parameters.
The scales are so imbalanced.
Like one is completely,
it's like having a child is dependent on the other [inaudible] they're doing
that for a couple of years,
two,
three years that I've been communicating with you.
But you've been in this,
you know,
essentially like a submarine,
you can't go anywhere in it.
It's like,
and then it comes up to the surface and you finally get out and they're like,
well,
I want the dynamic to stay.
The same does finally free and they can't be controlled and they're horrible,
horrible people.
So now the horrible person starts doing the horrible things.
Either it's there,
there are drug addicts,
they're liars,
they're closeted,
gay or bisexual.
And then they or they use the outside person for money on the inside.
This one check is like,
I got $800,000 from tricks on the side and the closeted gay think what she's,
what she's referring to is basically punchy mansplain me.
Well,
how dare,
cause it sounds like you're saying like there's a problem with,
with the gays.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I mean they're all,
what you're referring to is somebody who basically didn't tell the person who,
uh,
they had been dating on the outside,
that they in fact are gay or bi.
So now the person on the outside,
it's like,
wait a minute.
You like,
you know women too.
I didn't know that.
And he's like,
oh yeah.
Oh yeah.
I forgot to tell you that
a lot of lying,
there's,
there's just like a lot convicts lie a lot.
Just like,
like,
Yay.
Yeah.
Well,
so what is this cool guy want?
He wants to,
Oh yeah.
Can we go back to this awesome guy?
He seemed really,
really cool.
It seemed like he just,
he's just a sad,
just hope
that there's some woman or women out there plural,
um,
who really like,
having their push.
Yeah.
That's,
that's all I really want,
you know?
Um,
to be truthful,
that's all I keep asking God for.
I just,
honest to God,
just want to lick pussy.
That's,
that's where my heart said,
that's where my mind's at.
Hey guys,
if you're out there and you're interested in me and your friend on this site of
mine and you really want to have that done,
okay.
Now the same.
Seriously interested in doing that.
Yeah.
It seems,
I mean,
it doesn't seem unreasonable.
Well,
when you're including it to your prayers to God,
he means it.
Dear God,
cure my cancer.
Take care of my grandma.
I want to lick pussy.
Little lot of it.
Yeah.
Man,
I think I'd get that prayer a lot.
I think.
Um,
I dunno.
I think putting it out there though is a cool thing.
I think God probably does get that prayer a lot.
I really do.
I think God does.
I think there's a lot of people out there who was like,
please let me get my dick sucked.
What do you think God gets asked for the most money.
Definitely money.
Health and then pussy licks.
Yeah.
I mean I think a lot of people probably ask God for Love,
love,
just kind of Nice.
But I think,
I think there's definitely,
he probably gets more sexual prayers from men.
It's mostly the guys that are like,
please let me get my dates.
I please let me.
I think we actually,
um,
it's,
it's probably fair to assume that God has his own,
um,
anthem in his head that goes,
like every time that prayer comes in he's like,
here we go,
here we go again.
He's fucking cool guys.
Guy Wanting to get his pussy licked.
His man pussy.
Like,
I mean,
that guy is not the most attractive for those listening.
No,
but he's done at summit.
There's a woman out there who would let it happen.
I said,
look,
if there's one lesson we've learned from love after lockup is that there's
somebody for everybody.
Yeah,
that's true with the Internet now you can find anybody through some of those
losers that I'm are reaching out to the uh,
to the prisoners like they can get completely hosed.
There's still like,
I love her so much.
She's so dark and if such poor self esteem,
that's really the other key ingredient to dating an inmate is that you have
really bad self esteem.
And that's why I dug experiences cause they're also always like right.
There's always the,
well the last person broke up with me or dumped me.
You're doing this to me so now,
now I'm going to play it safe data.
And then they always put that person in debt.
The prisoner and inmate finds a way to siphon the money out of them.
They're all in debt because of the breast.
It's great.
Really a good one.
I find it real quick because people asked us this and we wanted to make a,
so last week of course the great big daddy Kane was on,
which was awesome.
Really Fun.
A lot of people mentioned or sent messages that there was something wrong with
the video quality on Youtube and that it was a,
the highest resolution was three 60 p and they were like,
what is up with that?
And you know,
I started talking to blue band about it.
You said that you didn't know and then you reached out to youtube what they say
to you,
right?
Yeah,
I reached out to our youtube contact and
it seems like it's a bug.
Uh,
it is now being escalated.
So they are currently working on trying to bring,
but it's a youtube glitch.
Yeah,
it's a,
yeah,
it's just nothing that we did.
Oh yeah.
This is the first time it's happened to us.
Not sure why it happened.
Okay.
So that was the main thing though.
It wasn't like we decided to record it and upload it differently.
It's something internal on their part.
Right.
All right.
Um,
can I bring up something very quickly?
Yeah.
Before,
yeah.
Before we have to,
We have to make it.
Yeah.
Now let,
before we bum everyone out.
I just want to say that I had such a wonderful time watching you with your hero,
big Daddy Kane.
And like I said,
you don't really get joyful about much.
Um,
but it was great seeing you just ear to ear with him and it inspired me to reach
out to my heroes and I'm currently on a campaign to get Kim and Kelly deal here
of the breeders.
Kim Jill formally the basis for the pixies.
I'm a huge fan of your huge might know this.
I got to meet him once on the street and I practically,
I always with you,
shit,
my pants were on Hyperion silver lake and I don't care about celebrities,
but I do love the deal sister.
I think we were walking by say cheese and uh,
itchies and uh,
yeah.
Say Geez,
it's a cheese shop.
And he told me to talk to her and I did and I was so scared.
But guys listen.
So Kelley deal.
I've,
I've reached out.
Kim is not on Twitter,
but Kelly is,
and I've reached out on Twitter and she's so far retweeted my tweet.
She's like the tweet.
Oh,
I need your guys' help to get Kevin Kelly's on her hand show.
So here we go guys.
Let's get mommy power on it.
It is at Kelly,
d l k e l l e y.
let her know.
Uh Huh.
Okay.
Uh,
and let her know that I would love to have Shane,
her sister on your mom's house to plug any upcoming maybe concert dates.
I know they tour is the breeders.
Anyways,
there you go.
I'm putting it out there in the universe.
That would be my big daddy Kane,
so to speak.
And is this,
this isn't your confession though,
is it?
Or is it,
no,
I'm so embarrassed.
What is it?
I'm really,
this is something I have not revealed to you.
I kept it from me today.
I kept it from everybody.
This is a scaring,
isn't exclusive.
It's,
this is,
uh,
you'll notice that I haven't reached for the Fart Mike today and it's because
this morning in the kitchen I was making myself a smoothie and,
and I farted and then a little wet
and,
and I wasn't wearing any underwear under my pajamas.
I know I don't wear any underwear in my pajamas.
And I was standing in the kitchen and I just farted,
I feel like wet down my leg.
And I was like,
I don't know where,
where that,
it's Friday.
And I went upstairs and newer in the memory you were upstairs and I was like,
oh I gotta think I gotta take a dump.
You didn't know at that point.
He did though.
I figured it out.
I kid,
cause I didn't know if it was a shard or kind of come out of another room,
throw those patients away.
Did you throw them away?
They're in the trash.
It's just a little bit of Shit.
We behave.
I just want to know how much was it.
So here's the deal,
man.
Last night we had pizza,
the cauliflower crust pizza with all those meat toppings.
And so I sat down and do Brown and it was like liquid came out of me.
So I sharted.
And the reason I sharted cause it was like liquids deal man,
but it was liquid brown.
It didn't hurt like diarrhea.
It was just all liquid it is that what it's short is,
it's like it's not necessarily,
I mean a sharp doesn't have to be exclusively liquid.
No,
cause I had one,
I remember we were flying to Africa.
That was my first shot ever.
2011 we were at the international Everman Atlanta airport at Hartsfield Jackson
ready to board a 16 hour flight to Johannesburg.
And Christina was like,
I'm going to get some tacos.
He wants some.
I was like,
I'm good.
And then three talks right away and that's why she's like shorter.
But that shot was different because it was like a Hershey kiss mashed into the
thing and do Appannie.
But this one was liquid baby.
It was like,
it was a liquid fart.
Have you ever had that?
Yeah.
You know what?
I had it when we lived in Redondo.
I remember.
I know.
Exactly.
Glad we're on this.
We're trying this juicing thing.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And there was something called like something green,
like all the green you need or some shit.
And it was a scoop of this powder.
So I was standing also in the kitchen.
Yeah,
I remember.
And I forward,
it was just liquid,
but it was,
I mean it was big.
I was like,
oh.
And then just water,
water works and that's what happened.
And then the next day I did it again.
You,
you ate the same thing.
I didn't know for sure.
I thought maybe all something was up with my stomach.
This morning I did the green powder again,
farted,
all water,
and then I dump the fucking powder down the sink.
I was like,
I said,
this is how you'll lose weight on this.
Collaroy yeah.
Well it made me think about are you kept that secret?
I kept it.
I kept,
I was a little ashamed because by the time I'd figured it out because I thought
it,
you know,
I don't know what this is.
And I sat down and by the time I'd figured it out,
I was shitting already.
And I don't want to call you in and tell you.
And then I was like,
I should save it for the show because this is kind of a big deal.
But it made me think about the very important question,
which is do far,
it's pushed to shit out.
And I have to say in the case of a shark,
yes they do.
Yes they do push.
It was the pizza.
It was,
cause that's really all I ate yesterday and ate a lot of it and it was that
cauliflower crust.
It gives me farts and mad dumps every time.
God.
Unbelievable man.
I can't believe I shot 42 years old and I had my first like liquid sharp.
Oh boy.
Isn't that exciting.
It's really exciting.
It's really something.
So now we're,
we forget onto the batch.
Are we talking about or the year before that?
I want to,
uh,
just bring up that this,
Thursday,
Dr drew after dark,
the audio comes out Thursday and the video will come out Friday,
correct?
Yep.
On our Youtube Channel at 12:00 PM on Friday.
Doctor drew after dark,
the video will be uploaded.
All right.
The debut episode features your very own,
Christina p.
Uh,
we also have,
uh,
we have four in the bag right now.
We shouldn't do,
and we'll,
we're going to keep recording them so we're going to keep going.
It was such a fun,
she's really fun.
I did one a,
you did one,
Bobby lead did one.
Yep.
Yeah.
Oh,
so the other one,
red band.
Brian Redman.
Yeah.
And they're good because doc or doctor drew,
I mean he's just such a great talent in house,
but like greater conversation.
He breaks down clips.
He really gets under the hood with you on different things.
I really enjoy it.
No.
Yeah,
it's going to be [inaudible].
All right,
so don't forget that,
that,
that'll just come on youtube.
If you're,
if you subscribed to this,
you'll just get the video update,
so that'd be great.
And then his,
his,
uh,
audio,
if you want to just download,
you need to find doctor drew after dark,
but you can,
you can subscribe to it right now,
right?
Yeah.
Follow us on Twitter,
uh,
drew after dark on Twitter.
Um,
and also we'll be,
we'll be tweeting out the links to that too easily.
You subscribed
and we give out the email and the phone number you can like have questions,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
we'll have that ready to go.
All right.
Here's the big uh,
update before we move on to some,
some clips here.
Uh,
it is over between us and Morton's.
I can't believe it.
I'm,
it's almost like one firing.
Okay.
That was devastating.
Yeah.
To firings from sponsors is kind of crazy this year.
Morton's fired us.
Yeah.
Um,
over the weekend and they said we just don't fit their brand objective right
now.
Um,
they don't fit our brand.
They were upset that we,
you did bring up the dry and the wet aged beef,
but you didn't elaborate,
I guess was the place that I wasn't as familiar with certain products.
You weren't knowledgeable enough about it.
I was just there last week,
by the way.
Yeah.
And they treated me like I was a celebrity.
That's always what they do before they fire you,
they pump you up.
Yeah.
When I got fired from Chelsea lately,
same thing guy.
You're doing a great job here.
And then they fired me the next day.
It's crazy.
But yeah,
so they fired us again.
I had to give a couple grand back
to the uh,
the,
you know,
the people that initially gave it to us for the paint job here.
Yeah.
Um,
anyways,
so we're not with them,
but we still have steakhouse vibes.
So,
uh,
just putting a call out to any steak house that wants to be affiliated with this
show.
Well I think you would just be easier cause we've already got the set painted
like a steakhouse that if we could actually have a steak house sponsors would
just be more convenient.
Get a steak house or are you run one or own one?
And you know,
you want to be affiliated with your mom's house just to send us an email,
your mom's podcast@gmail.com and make sure you put steak house in the subject
line.
And this way there's no,
no misunderstanding.
And also you may want to watch the show before you sign up to be our sponsor.
Yeah.
Do it.
Do a Google search for uncle Terry.
Why mh before you pull the trigger.
Because you know what,
we're not going to stop doing what we do on this show.
No,
of course.
For a GED sponsor Tom,
no,
we're,
no we're not.
We're not.
We have integrity.
That's right.
When you were going to do the show the way we want it and we lost millions of
dollars because we did kind of show we do.
But you know what?
Forget it.
The fans are more important to me.
Keeping this show with integrity and doing what we like is more important to me
than any kind of sponsorship.
I agree.
Just so you know guys.
We're going to keep it real.
So something else happened and my end,
look,
we appreciate the time we were with with,
with Morton's too.
So we just tell them that a couple grand and I'll still say they make a great,
uh,
steak.
Yeah,
it does.
Are you,
will you still eat it more in tweeter?
We banned from Morton's or we allowed,
I don't think we're a band
because all eyes,
all I saw,
I mean,
unless there's a followup coming was just that the relationship with the show is
over.
Gotcha.
But we're still allowed on the prison.
I like Mcdonald's where we're not even allowed in southern cal.
Well,
I had a hankering for a cheeseburger the other day and I had to second like give
it a second thought before I tried going through the drive through because I
don't want to get banned.
Recognize with my children.
Yeah.
You know how that goes.
Um,
so something magical happening.
I know you're,
you've been itching to talk about this guy.
This is really cool.
So,
wow.
Do you know that like
Halley's comet?
Yup.
Yeah.
Like once every,
I don't know,
75 something like that.
Sure,
sure,
sure.
There comes a time in one's life where one can see something or someone that
gives a dose of like natural adrenaline.
There's an excitement.
It's,
you know what it's like.
Yeah.
It's like when you're watched back in the day,
American idol and then everybody at it shows all the people who can't hit the
notes.
And then someone comes in like,
I don't know,
Kelly Clarkson or somebody and you're like,
Whoa,
star of the show you,
it's like you recognize the star quality or you see that someone's special.
It's like the first time I saw GG Allen.
Yes.
And you're like,
this guy's a star.
Yeah.
They have that charisma.
They have something unique.
It's very rare
here.
I mean,
you know,
we've been in comedy for a long time now and you know,
rarely do you see someone hit the stage where you're like,
wow.
Right.
That's special.
So this young man hit the,
I can't even look.
He's so,
his star quality is so bright.
Yeah.
Look directly.
It's like there's a new
social media star.
Yeah.
And for,
for whatever reason,
he was discovered,
I would say,
even though he's been around,
it was discovered over the weekend.
People found his posts,
his videos,
and I was like,
is this real?
And there's,
there's just so much going on with him.
Um,
I don't even know if I can set it up correctly other than like,
why don't you just dip your toe in the water and see what's what's what here
with this guy?
I can tell you visually.
Visually already I am
blown away.
Yeah,
no,
he's got it.
He's got his own unique style.
I mean like sure.
This beard is,
is like,
like no other beard I've ever seen.
He's got,
he's got the thin line that was the Puerto Rican pencil,
but that's just in the goatee.
But then he's got a beard separate from it and is,
it has its own designs and then he's got the shaved head,
diamond earrings,
beards on beards on beards on me.
Yeah,
go ahead.
It's been awhile,
hasn't it?
I decided to make a video.
Okay.
Since I'm stuck on the four oh five.
Oh on a lot of way to Santa Monica.
I think the topic of this video will be something a little more personal.
Let's talk about why bad ass.
Good looking rich guys don't have girlfriends like me.
Why is it that girls will date a guy that has half my wallet?
Half my Dick,
half my car,
half my bank,
half my personality,
half my looks half my wardrobe,
half my sexual prowess.
But they'll pass up a guy like me who's Fon,
good booking,
interesting,
edgy,
educated and wants to be a dad.
No,
let's talk about that.
Let's talk about it.
I like it.
Great.
Beautiful Tea.
Oh,
the dude is like,
I mean,
it looks great.
Great.
Do you look at those eyelashes?
Look at the browser,
a fleet,
the fuck out you.
Yeah,
man.
He's got like,
let's tell,
it looks like,
uh,
this is one of his vehicles.
Uh,
lots of stickers on the stickers on it and they tell you I'm an individual.
I like things other people don't like it.
It's like a pickup truck.
But you could tell he's got like,
um,
you know,
like he's got modified exhaust on it.
There's just,
there's a lot going on at night.
This is an interesting premise.
I want to know before he's going to give the answer.
Why do you think
some women,
no flags?
I don't know what the problem is.
Like,
why do some women not want to date a guy who's got the money?
Right.
Did the Brown,
the car that wants to be at like,
you know what it is Tom?
Some people star shines too brightly for it.
True.
Yeah.
A lot of people can't handle this stuff.
A lot of people can't handle it.
I mean it,
some people can't,
can't handle being around success.
That absolutely true.
Intimidator called haters.
Yeah.
And I think a lot of women out there maybe aren't seeing this guy's potential
and maybe he needs to convince you and maybe it needs to explain it to people.
You might be honest,
I'm here.
Let's,
as you get older you understand.
It's actually a compliment.
Why a guy like me is single and then I look around and guys that have big ass
bellies or you know by all their shoes at Kmart have girlfriends.
Why do they have girlfriends?
I'll,
why don't I,
if you look too good and you got to go on and on.
Women,
our mother fucking Hayden Cots,
they don't like to see you ball.
Yeah.
See my my theory.
Exactly.
Yup.
They don't like to see you ball.
They don't like to see you succeed.
They don't like you looking better than that.
They don't want you being desirable because that's gonna make them vulnerable to
you leaving their bitch ass.
Yup.
You hit the gym,
you ball in some Badass Nike's or Jordans and dress cool and you ain't got a
girl homey.
It's a compliment to you.
That means these bitches can't step up to your level.
Yeah.
This dude,
truth knowledge was kind of insight,
you know?
That's what I'm looking for.
Women are mother fucking Hayden cots.
Yup.
Yeah.
So stupid.
Huh?
It's true.
Fucking dumb.
What do you think is true?
What he's saying?
That the,
they're not smart enough to see what he's got to offer.
I think that,
I think he's onto something with,
um,
with the fact that there's definitely some haters out there.
When men or women see somebody who's really got it going on,
like this guy that there'll be like,
Shamal what bro?
Fuck,
I'm fading,
homie.
I mean,
it's true though,
right?
Absolutely.
I just seen that intimidated sometimes and you know,
we have to see,
we have to,
and they're intimidated.
What does he have to offer?
Well,
I mean the,
in this case,
it's who's got a lot to offer?
I don't take it personally.
Look,
I still fuck a lot,
but
those girls that fuck me,
they're afraid to be with me,
but they'll run back and be with a little boy who doesn't even have a car and
lives with his grandma.
Now.
Does that make sense?
And I'm,
like I said,
women are internally very jealous creatures.
They're very insecure.
They constantly measure themselves and they're even competing with you as their
boyfriend,
as their husband has there.
Man,
that's basically what's up.
So you guys out there,
it was a pleasure,
man.
Until next time.
Bye Bye.
So,
so he's saying
it's the competitive nature in women that that's why he can't have a
relationship?
I think so.
He's making an interesting point,
right?
I think you're right.
I think he's also saying that,
you know,
in most,
let's say,
traditional relationships,
um,
you find that in a lot of cases,
in the traditional relationship,
the man goes,
concedes that the woman is the star,
so to speak.
She's the looker.
She's,
you know,
put the attention on her.
He's saying,
I got a little too much going on.
Oh,
be the one that shines.
You can shine too,
but don't think you're going to out shine
me.
Right.
And he,
he,
but he's also saying,
yeah,
that the woman is competitive and,
and,
and wants to take that star from him.
Yeah,
exactly.
I mean,
you,
you know,
I don't want there to be any confusion.
This is not the cool guy club.
Oh,
this is not the cool guy in class.
This is the,
a different,
what club is this?
I think this is the rich guy club.
Ah,
the bar or club.
You're genuinely,
this guy's a superstar.
Yeah.
I mean,
there's more,
that's what I like to hear.
What he has to say.
I mean,
look,
I hope there's someone out there worthy of him.
Yeah.
There's,
there's definitely more stuff.
Um,
he put out,
um,
let's see.
Oh,
he did an Instagram live.
So just so you know,
he puts a lot of his stuff on Instagram.
Okay.
Oh boy.
And he has,
um,
he has like,
he's got a lot going on a coordinator.
So Graham,
because he's got such a look happen.
You've got a lot going on.
So let me tell you,
first of all,
a lot of money.
Anyway,
he's going into houses and he's told us I got a lot of money.
I got a lot of houses.
I got a lot of cars.
I got a private chef.
You have millions of dollars in the bank,
right?
Uh,
I do.
I hear,
I don't mean to look.
He is fabulous.
Yeah.
I'm,
I like the,
and we're going to watch another clip of him.
He's toned down the facial hair,
right?
Cause
that is from a few years ago.
Oh,
okay.
So this is more update and he got a new hat.
He's got some jewelry,
which I honestly,
it made me regret canceling my jewelry order.
Really.
Remember I bought that.
Um,
I ordered that chain.
Right.
And I think it was Pete Holmes made me feel very insecure about the order.
Well,
it's,
it cannot,
it's not a great investment piece.
Yeah.
But it's about shining.
It's about,
you know,
the resale is not very good on yeah,
but I'm not going to sell.
It's about letting people know what time it is.
I let them know.
And so anyways,
this guy has definitely,
then people know that this guy's a peacock.
He's definitely a peacock or you know,
letting everybody see is plumage and not everybody's worthy.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's hear what he has to say.
It's pretty cool.
And we got in here,
not even 400 man,
the artwork,
there wasn't $30 but thank you.
This is one piece of artwork.
I mean,
y'all don't want to comment on the fact that I'm sitting in $1,000 custom movie
theater chair and I have five of them.
I mean retarded man,
this law,
all these people under 35 what's wrong with you guys?
Why are you so angry?
Bitter?
Was it nine 11 you guys felt robbed of your youth?
Was it Columbine?
Was it all these mass shootings that you guys got terrorists struck in you from
your media and mom and dad?
What the fuck?
Yeah.
I was happy.
Conscious too.
I liked that he's aware of these social issues contributing to the today's.
That's true.
But he didn't use the r word and I don't appreciate that.
Yeah,
that's a very offensive,
yeah.
I was happy when people got rich.
I'm still happy when people get rich on a game show or from one in the lottery
or from winning American idol or from success or a comeback like mock God.
This is just the retardation of your generation.
How long the
somebody just,
you know,
this is from a live thing he did on Instagram.
Yeah.
And just,
you have to watch this guy on youtube.
By the way,
if you're not watching this on youtube,
he's amazing.
Somebody just wrote your fat.
Yeah.
Um,
do you get microbladed browse?
Somebody wrote,
I'm fake flex.
Huh?
That's all you got to say.
I'm fake flexion.
I'm a fraud.
Right.
If I was a fraud,
where's my goal for me?
Page?
Like all of y'all have acting like you have cancer or trying to get money for
your mom.
Yeah.
I mean,
but look at those chains though.
Lots of chains.
You don't like those?
He have no,
those are beautiful chains.
And we look at that outside.
Why?
But outside?
Sure.
Yeah,
the Cuban one there.
It's a very nice,
uh,
you know what I like most is he's got a bedazzled hat on.
You see?
It's like a cheetah pattern or whatever.
And then he's got some sparkle and there's stones that look real gems in there.
Yeah.
I saw a separate post where he talked about it.
Oh,
okay.
He spares no expense.
Oh,
this guide.
I mean,
money just falls out of his pocket.
Sure.
Yeah.
I mean he just,
dude,
he goes like private chefs.
Yeah.
Probably private planes.
Definitely homes,
multiple homes,
tons of cars,
jewelry,
bedazzled hats.
Yeah.
Yes.
Let's,
what else is he's talking about?
Uh,
let's see.
Is there,
is there any other,
that's it for this?
Uh,
that's it for this live stream that we read,
but we have another 20 minutes that we will have prepped for next week.
Great.
Good.
That I think only we might have access to.
Yeah,
but we also have some screenshots in another video.
I don't know if you want to save it for later and go through some of that.
Oh,
let's go.
Let's,
Oh yeah,
no,
I want to,
I'm,
I'm in Thomas and thrills.
Please show me.
This is all we've been talking about in her home.
What's this guy's name?
Hardrock.
Nick hardrock neck.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Every now and then just the diamond comes
along.
Yeah.
There's like,
here's just to give you more insight.
Okay,
so why don't you read,
read the captain.
This is his caption.
If I can get past the image,
I know it's a lovely a Selfie as a son.
Do you see you see the chain?
I want to see the chains,
Tom.
I see the multiple chain,
by the way,
since we're putting it out there and we're discussing,
we're looking,
40th birthday is coming up.
Yeah,
chains.
He's got,
he's got outside one.
The thick ones.
I will.
You turn 40 once.
Gotcha.
How many,
how much money do you think that is?
I mean for him,
I'm sure it's nothing.
I'm assuming that's,
I don't know.
If we get another steakhouse sponsor,
the answer is yes.
Then I can get the chain.
You can get the chain.
Ah,
that'd be awesome.
He's got the,
he's got an eye.
His eyebrows are very fleet.
He looks like a genie,
doesn't eat.
His eyebrows are amazing.
He looks like a,
and his lips are kind of,
he's doing duck lips for the water.
I think that's natural.
I don't think he's doing it.
Oh,
okay.
He doesn't need fillers.
Can you please read this caption?
Okay.
This is what he writes.
Once you've dated me,
it's mathematically impossible to do better than me in selecting another mate.
After breakups,
my exes have endured the likes of terminal brain cancer,
and in parentheses,
he writes no bullshit suicide by lethal injection.
Decades of psychotherapy,
present time or in other milder examples had become gay or settled for men who
in some way or another reminded said,
x of me,
you will never do better than me.
Hashtag I said never.
Wow.
Yeah.
22 likes on this one.
Hardrock neck.
Oof.
So women go crazy after they break up with him.
It sounds,
where he drives them to suicide.
What?
You know how when you do comedy?
Yeah.
Especially when you start,
you write a bio.
That's bullshit.
But I mean you have to kind of summarize your story.
Yeah.
This caption summarizes his,
why don't you go ahead and give it a read.
So this is his bio.
Born in Las Vegas,
Nevada.
Grew up in Manhattan beach,
California,
graduated from UC Berkeley on my 12th Mercedes Benz.
Okay.
That's just thrown in stats.
Here's his other sets.
Houses and Irvine cove,
del Mar,
San Francisco,
West Hollywood,
Las Vegas.
Of course he writes in parentheses,
Dallas,
Texas and Tokyo,
Japan.
Over $30,000 worth of tattoos on my body.
Okay.
Usually shop at Bristol farms.
Gelson's our whole foods market.
This is like Brody Stevens,
like when he lists where he shops and stuff.
Oh,
this is the vest.
He averages one Amazon package a week.
Okay.
That's down from two a week this time last year.
Oh,
where a good $350 million.
Not counting the house I live in.
Wow.
Prefer eating pussy from the back.
Okay.
Love and I mean love getting my dick sucked almost 300 pounds,
but carry it like I'm 210 pounds.
Alexa,
the shit out of my house.
San Francisco 40 niners fan could live on Sushi and princey.
Sometimes I do excelled at tennis and soccer in my youth and could have easily
turned pro easily have fucked everyone in the porn business that I wanted to
hate cigarettes,
fake tits,
fake eyelash extensions and anyone who was stingy with cheese on my food in
general donated $500,000 to the Trump slash pence campaign in 2016 think that's
good enough for now,
don't you?
Wow.
I mean,
listen,
this guy average is one Amazon package a week.
That part blew me away.
He shops on the regular at Bristol Farms Gelson's or whole foods.
He means organic money.
He's all fucked.
Trader Joe's,
Dude,
I don't feel the traders 300 pounds,
but he didn't know,
but he looks to 10 I believe it.
He looks great.
Here's his other caption,
ladies.
I promise that having a finance boyfriend like me will literally make you come
the second I tap my dick on the,
I can't finish this.
Thanks.
I mean,
I can pull ahead.
It will literally make you come this second.
I tap my dick on the edges of your pussy lips before insertion hashtag every
fucking time he's as crime.
It's a little intense.
Look,
isn't it?
Look at him.
He looks like a gauging.
Yeah.
Fuck you.
He's gonna fuck.
Yeah.
I wish we could do your eyebrows.
Microbladed like this guy.
I know.
Okay.
Oh,
whoa.
Boy.
I love when people take selfies of themselves in bed.
It's so sexy and so romantic,
you know?
And they're like,
I'm just laying here,
inspired me.
Lips pursed.
Oof.
The beard caption is any finance white girls with tons of ass and hips who can
handle an 11 inch Dick.
Oh,
they come over tonight.
DME.
11 inches.
Wow.
God,
I didn't know about this and he's worth $350 million.
I mean,
this is just building it and building.
Why is this guy single will,
that's the thing has got to be the haters.
I'm thinking it's gotta be the haters.
It's gotta be the haters.
This guy is great.
This guy has everything.
I got to set him up with my step sister.
What's this say,
gene?
This says,
told my private chef to make protein style cheeseburgers and hold the fries for
my lunch today because my new girlfriend is 18 and still in high school
hashtag he's so rich.
Oh my God.
That's really looks really gourmet.
It looks a little like in and out,
but I'm sure it's not in and out.
No.
That's a protein style.
Actually having a private chef name.
No,
he's so lucky.
I wish I did awesome.
Yeah,
this guy's Rad.
Oh Shit.
How a man was $75 million cash in the bank.
Eats breakfast on the daily wait,
I thought he had a 350 million.
No,
I that was his net worth.
Oh,
maybe you don't understand numbers.
I don't,
but that's the value of what he's worth and this is cash value.
Wow.
Liquid liquid liquid.
And this guy,
what is it?
75 million in cash.
Eat for breakfast.
I see an Omelet.
Yeah.
Looks like English muffin side of fruit bowl.
What's on the left plate there?
What does the head,
it looks like some Zucchini smashed up.
I don't know.
This guy's really,
he's a ball.
Yeah,
right.
You guys got to do a deep dive on this guy.
Yeah.
Hard rock nick
on Instagram.
Hard rock.
Nick.
Yourself a favor.
Just the way it sounds.
Okay.
Then we pulled some,
uh,
a VA can do it.
This is some,
some stuff from his Facebook because this dude is just,
he's just,
he's just blowing everybody away on Facebook.
He is Nicholas and I.
C h.
O.
L.
A.
S rock.
Joe Hansen.
This has a photo of a lovely lady who is leaning over the sink,
like looking in the mirror.
She does her makeup and she has quite a rear end and hard rock.
Nick posted ladies,
if you have an ass like this and are a pure white American,
born female in parentheses,
not mixed with Mexican or Israeli and should it have light eyes and a career and
we'll let me put my face in it.
Every time you bend over the sink to do your makeup,
get at me.
That's quite an offer.
Wow.
You know you kind of fit a line.
I'm thinking,
I mean if he's into Adam might be too for it.
Definitely too old.
Fuck.
Do you think you are?
You think you're worthy of that shit?
I'm definitely not worthy of hardrock Nag this though.
Okay,
here we go guys.
He posted,
but if anybody listening is interested in dating this guy,
he's got 10 turnoffs in a woman in order 10 turn offs in a woman in order of
level of turn off at nes.
So guys are women.
If you're listening and you're into hard rock.
Nick,
here's the 10 things he does not like.
Number one.
Oh my God,
why don't we start with 10 uh,
10.
Okay.
Won't shop slash ee slash do yoga anywhere unless she has a coupon slash Groupon
magazine clipping for it.
Lol.
He doesn't want you to be cheap.
Cheap.
Number nine has a child from a previous man.
Oh there it goes around already.
Eight has visible facial hair.
Even peach fuzz with three exclamation marks.
Better get that shit lasered off laser and he likes some hairless number seven,
prudish sexually.
Number six never says you.
I understand that one.
I get it.
He has a lot to offer.
Number five wears perfume from Walmart or Tj Maxx,
et cetera.
Okay for wears too much makeup.
Okay,
turn off three vegetarian.
well he's very health conscious.
If you look at him and his diet,
he's,
he keeps it lean and he keeps it carries it carries it.
Like he's two 10 smoker of any kind is number two.
And number one non Caucasian is his big turnoff.
The most turned off he can go
and non Caucasian.
So I know there's a lot of tears streaming down.
People listening,
people watching and being like,
what?
Well,
no wonder you can't find love.
This is quite a tight list.
I mean we kind of,
I don't want to be the type of person that would assume they can give hardrock
nick,
any advice?
But we did watch a lot of millionaire matchmakers.
Yeah.
She was always against the people with lists.
She said,
I can't go into love that way.
I agree.
And he's talking about being single,
but he's got these lists,
but at least he knows what makes his Peter Heart starts with white,
white,
white power.
Yeah.
Wow.
I don't know if he's white though.
I don't think he can.
I don't think he is.
I don't think he can claim like he,
he's wanting pure p well,
whatever.
Yeah.
Like I don't think he himself is pure Caucasian.
You're my,
if I'm a betting lady,
I would go native.
Do you think even maybe your tribe or Persia?
Here's a back and I watched the live stream.
He said very aggressively that he is neither Persian or Jewish bull shit.
Well,
he's from La,
right?
He's an la native.
I'm going to go Persian on.
I Dunno.
Hell yeah.
He's making a point to say no dude.
Armenian,
Armenian man.
You realize if he's not what you're doing right now.
What am I doing?
Really?
Armenian.
Actually.
I don't think so.
Yeah,
I just,
I know this type dude.
This is,
this is definitely la guy.
Um,
two selfies for the best followers in the world.
Happy Friday.
Hashtag that cock bulge though.
Oh my God.
This guy is Joe.
That's 11 inches.
It's got a lot of tats too.
Uh,
okay.
This is a photo of some things he picked up at the grocery store.
I'm done.
Uh,
he wants everything to smell great.
He got,
uh,
he got mouthwash.
She got gain and glade and he said,
I,
truth is,
I put those glade cones in my walk in closet.
The mouthwash is for my guest bathrooms.
Hashtag Thicke bitches only.
Okay.
I mean,
it really is a gift that never,
it hasn't stopped.
He's really amazing.
I really hope he picks up the posts because his followers are picking up.
Oh my gosh,
this is a,
a,
a bottle of balsamic vinegar.
And he said,
I told my private chef that I want to price their salad for dinner night.
You told me to pick up some expensive balsamic vinegar,
which I just did exclamation mark.
Personally.
I would have the chef pick it up.
I get it.
I would too.
Or instacart.
Like if you're that rich instacart died.
Yeah.
But he probably wants to look at it.
Hold it.
You know,
nobody's getting sure.
Hi.
Hey.
Yeah.
Oh Shit.
Uh,
I love fresh,
horrible egg sprinkle with salt and pepper for a high protein snack before my
chef makes dinner.
All right.
That's really cool man.
There's a lot more.
I kind of want to save some of hard rock near.
Yeah.
He's special.
Watch one of these videos with one of our guests.
So I'm going to save it for just a little bit later.
Um,
in a moment we're going to have,
uh,
our friend come in here and talk to us.
Oh yeah.
About a couple of things because we need it.
We need to sit down with him.
You know,
you better check your weight.
Privilege,
Tom.
I will check my weight.
Privilege.
Have you heard that?
That's the latest form of privilege.
Yes.
I sign on Twitter.
There's white privilege.
Now I know because of fat people like Bert.
But anyways,
we'll be back to talking about photos and Dick's after this quick break
and we're back.
We are back in studio with a dear friend,
a great comedian.
Uh,
somebody who greatly helps out this show does a lot of producing for us.
So direct
director,
choreographer.
It's Josh Potter.
Everybody.
Hey,
hey.
Hey
ladies.
Lemon.
Yeah.
So this weekend I make,
I'm all wet face
all those tears streaming down.
Um,
we had a good time.
That was fun this weekend.
It was a fun weekend.
Uh,
boss life,
baby life tour,
bus champ.
Her mother,
Gangbang Boston guys,
man,
just play so many crime chicks.
They're just,
believe me,
there's Dna all over that thing.
Josh,
are you scoring checks on the bang bus or what?
All Day?
Make that rock
all damn day for sure.
Buying them up by the pump.
They got 'em stack.
That's right.
You got shit bunks for different hose.
Yeah.
Um,
did you expect I did not expect,
I have not.
I've lived in La a long time now.
Long Beach was the shit that was so dope.
Yeah.
It doesn't even seem like La.
So like it seems far away.
Yeah.
But it's not,
it's right there.
It was unbelievable.
A lot of sluts there.
There was just a lot of everything and the crowd was fucking bonkers.
Yeah.
There's a reason.
Warren G's.
Yeah.
Ellen and the elements of seen snoop Dogg snoop Dogg's.
Uh,
but more importantly,
Josh,
we were talking about you this weekend.
You're finding you're lovable.
We adore you.
Uh,
but we don't know how you stay alive.
And Tom and I have come to the conclusion that you might be a human cockroach.
I,
well,
let's go through,
let's run through our list of,
Oh yeah,
we spend a lot of time with me this weekend and I've spent over the years.
Of course,
human doesn't,
Human Cochran's doesn't really eat.
Never.
You're like getting your life.
I've taken you out to these nice restaurants and you'll sometimes be like,
oh,
I'll have the,
and I'll be like,
and he's going to have an appetizer and he's going to like,
I'll make you order things,
order lunch here and last week everyone's ordering full meals and he's like,
I'll have a cup of soup.
Sounds like when I ordered today,
I got the soup of the day.
That's it.
Yeah.
You know you got bog myself down with some food.
What have you eaten so far today?
Nothing.
Okay.
That'll be my first noon.
Yeah,
it's Earl cockroach,
cockroach and then approach eating.
Okay.
The full game.
Incapable of regulating his body temperature.
He has like a near
psychotic persons body.
I think the only guy I've ever met who is this far off.
I mean most guys are like,
you know,
I prefer guys will be like,
I like a little cooler.
You don't really get bothered by the cold,
but you will wear a jacket if it's cold outside.
Oh yeah.
This guy.
I'll tell you some psycho.
I've never met anybody like him.
It'll be like 37 that's fine.
He'll be like,
he's like,
ah,
Kinda hot.
And I'm like,
what are you talking about?
He's like,
he's like,
you're not hot.
I'm like,
no,
no one's hot here.
The airport's dripping off his layers walking on in a tee shirt on the Jessica
crazy person,
total crazy pursued.
Those airports are fucked.
We were at a gig where they were,
it was like downstairs cavernous old theater and the guy,
the guy was wearing a parka that you would go like to hike Mount Everest and he
was like,
sorry,
they didn't turn the heat on and,
and Josh was like,
it feels great.
It doesn't feel great.
That t shirt on.
But how are you burning off any energy because you're not eating,
you're not.
You just have a high metabolism.
It feels,
I guess I I,
I don't think I was from Waterloo,
don't that?
That's true.
I'm from the cold.
I was born in the cold.
Okay,
wait,
tell her I didn't even tell her this.
Tell her the shower thing.
The shower thing you told me.
Oh,
I take cold showers.
What?
I end every shower by cranking the heat off and just letting the cold water.
That's my nightmare.
That is fine.
And how long do you do it for?
How will you tell me?
As long as I can tell you about it.
Why?
Why are you punishing yourself?
It's not a punishment.
It's like an invigoration thing.
It's time to close the shower down.
So let's crank up the cold water and just,
Oh my God,
it's my nightmare.
That is my fucking nightmare.
Your shower with Josh fighter,
we've determined that like if we did the road together,
I will murder you hot all the time.
Oh my God,
he wouldn't be able to tolerate our bedroom.
Oh my God.
I couldn't imagine.
Dream on top of sheets,
right?
I mean,
but you're,
the bed would just be a pool of blood.
Okay,
well let's go.
Let's get back.
Let's get back to Josh pattern.
The smoking of cigarettes smokes all the time.
How many cigarettes are we on now?
This week?
I mean this week per day to only,
I mean,
I don't smoke that much.
All that.
If I could smoke weed perpetually,
I would just do that.
Okay.
They're just a supplement,
you know,
supplement for weed.
Yeah,
pretty much the smoking,
I'm sorry to started the red bull.
I always see you suck.
And Don Don the red ball.
That's how many of those thing keeps me focused.
It keeps you focused.
So that's sugar and caffeine and the sugar free sugar free and then s and then
sleep.
I don't know what you're doing for that.
I don't either.
Okay.
I don't,
that's,
I mean I,
I'm bad at it.
Yeah.
I don't get a lot of it.
Right.
So you're a cockroach.
So sleep,
let's walk me through the night.
It depends on the night.
Uh,
during the,
the road.
Yeah.
I uh,
I got a couple hours on the bus,
you know,
but the buses that people say,
it's like the best sleep you ever have.
Cause it's rocking.
And I guess,
I don't know,
but it's still a moving car.
Yeah.
But what about,
we forgot about the last one.
He can't count.
Oh,
well,
yeah,
no,
he's a cockroach.
Maybe that all,
all those ingredients
together,
maybe
all these things combined.
You're right key.
It may be contributing to your sexual problems.
We thought with the body temperature thing that the heat is just keeping my
common.
My body could be so maybe that's it.
I am a hairy guy.
Probably more hairy than time.
You think the hair keeps you warm?
Yes.
Okay,
and my blood is thick.
Okay.
And I just like being cold.
You like being called?
Yes.
More than being hot by a mile.
Really?
That's my nephew.
That's my nightmare.
[inaudible] you and I are complete opposites like being cold.
Yes.
It feels good to be cold as opposed to being hot.
Of course.
Now hottest sweating.
I like,
I feel better.
But you spoke with doctor drew.
I've never heard somebody.
Okay.
I get hot.
I really get like I want to jump out of my fucking skin.
Yeah,
it really bothers you.
Yeah.
That's how I feel cold.
I get angry.
I'm upset that I have the,
I'm suffering the indignity of being called when there's other options for me.
I don't need to feel this way right now.
I just little why when you're hot,
you don't feel alive.
I don't know.
You feel like,
I hate that.
I hate feeling hot.
Um,
but when you talked to doctor drew about your ejaculations thanks.
So for those of us that aren't familiar,
walk us through your problem.
Uh,
well I can function sexually except for the punctuation point,
which is finishing without the aid of myself.
So you're
saying you have to hand manipulate.
Yes.
And for those who are saying that I might be gay,
I wish it was that fucking,
I wish that was the answer.
It was just a guy that if it was just that I was gay,
I would just be like,
yeah,
I'm gay.
And I would just fuck dudes.
And I would probably come all the time and maybe you should try it.
I mean,
if I could get a boner from a dude,
I would definitely go down with these girls.
Just so people know you,
you're,
you know,
you like women,
you're,
you're getting with women and then the,
you just can't finish.
Right.
You need to finish.
But maybe manually we need,
so you go,
you go watch this and then you put on a show for them?
Yes.
It depends how they want to get involved,
you know,
sometimes they're like,
here,
wait a minute.
Is this a kink?
No.
I would prefer to just jazz inside or what a doctor just feels about it.
Uh,
he has,
you know,
it's gonna take a little bit of communicating more and things like that.
Uh,
I think we determined that,
uh,
a nice prescription for a smoke show is in order just to test it out.
A fucking hottie.
Real pigs,
is that the,
sometimes you know here and there,
but let's call them open.
There's a lot of white privilege.
There's a lot of,
there's a lot of listeners out there and viewers.
Let's put the call out,
help Josh come.
He needs your help and if you need,
we'll come sponsor telethon.
Yeah.
Nice guy.
All right.
He doesn't sleep much.
Takes showers.
He's going to take it and you'll take them out.
You'll show them.
Yeah.
So let's get a little like just a really,
if you're willing and able reach out,
this is a boy that just needs your help.
Yes.
Yeah.
Help him out.
Let them try.
Just need us smoke
now.
Would you,
you'd be willing to date somebody in the entertainment adult entertainment
industry.
You find clothes or hey,
I actually would prefer to date a girl who's done porn.
I mean prefer,
I mean,
sure.
I guess I can go that way.
Prefer for,
I've never done it,
so I don't know what you're curious.
I am saying,
I think I could handle it for just froze for just four strokes a day.
You can help.
It's something that,
uh,
you know,
we want this to happen.
Yes,
for sure.
I want it to happen for my whole life.
So,
I mean,
if this doesn't work,
then you know,
we might have to consider other medical options,
but really,
maybe,
I mean,
if this doesn't work,
I don't know.
We'll have to take it to the next level.
We'll have to ask doctor drew with that is okay.
You know,
I hope,
I really do hope a really hot woman reaches out and she was like,
I'll go out with them and then we can test this theory.
Yeah.
It takes someone who's a Gamer and he just wants to come on as a comic fight
through it.
Oh,
before we forget,
let's talk about,
um,
what's your,
uh,
show coming up?
March 22nd Improv lab here in Hollywood.
Uh,
tickets in my bio on my Instagram and on my Twitter if you want to scoop them
up.
And what's the,
uh,
what's your,
what's the handle for your,
oh,
at j underscore potter is my Twitter and Josh underscore potter is my Instagram
because some asshole fucking took the other one.
There you go.
And listen,
he's hilarious.
There's a reason I've taken him,
uh,
on the road everywhere we learned another reason I think.
Well,
now that I'm an employee,
yeah.
What do you think my value is?
Like let's say if I died on the road.
Yeah.
What do you mean?
What do you think?
Like you could get for me,
like life.
I don't know if that
expense,
you know,
we discussed a thing going,
remember that Tracy Morgan was in this horrific bus accident and he lost,
he lost his friend and he was injured and Walmart settled for just extraordinary
because of its potential earnings.
So I was fantasizing about that.
Yeah,
like a,
we were going through a snowy pass to get to Rhea and I said,
hey man,
we might get some that Tracy Morgan and you guys were thinking like,
how much does Josh Potter World?
I'd be the one that dies.
He of course has to die.
But what I,
uh,
what I was thinking was like is that it would be kind of like money if we were
in this bus accident and that he's just a little hurt.
Like he's like,
ah,
my arm,
I think it might have broken my arm and that.
Then I'm like,
well,
I gotta get this money.
So then I,
I take a crowbar and I just started,
he was like,
it's just like laying there under a piece of,
you know,
part of the bus falls on me and I'm like,
Tom
and Tom's like,
it's too far.
You're too hurt is broken.
Then like shut up matches my style and he's on the phone with you or something.
He's like,
I'm fine,
Christina.
Joshua's to heart,
he's mortally injured.
I have to finish him up.
I'd be like,
Chris.
And then the cops show up and they're like,
what happened?
And I'm like,
well,
I,
he went flying like,
well it looks like he has like blunt force trauma to the head.
Like yeah,
all this shit was fun.
Crowbar when flying your bounce off his head six times and you know,
it was weird.
It was a lie.
All a blur.
You got to run this past your therapist.
And then they're like,
Tom,
Tom deserves a big check.
He had to go through this,
his own horrible experience.
Give them $100 million and I'll be like,
Ooh,
I miss job.
Got To
get some money from it too.
And they're like,
why is his but his skulls bashed.
That's really consistent with some foul play here.
Yeah,
man.
You know how the snow is.
I check with the driver.
Yeah.
My no more how you guys really had a good time on this trip pod talking about
ways to kill Josh Potter
next.
That was a lot of fun,
man.
Thanks for having me.
I'm going to have some soup.
I'm pretty pumped about it.
Jesus.
Yeah,
let's go get,
let's go get our lunch and we'll be back.
We'll be right
and we're back
and this is a real treat.
People did not know.
We didn't tease this and let people know secrets.
We are joined by Detroit's own.
Danny Brown.
Hey Man,
thank you guys for having me.
Dude.
This was like a such a trip when I first you not a DM to while ago.
I think it was that somebody tipped me off that I think you had mentioned our
podcast,
maybe an interview or something when it's like you're a big podcast fan I guess
in like the last few years.
I guess when you make so much music,
the last thing you want to do is listen to music.
Yeah,
some sense of like,
okay,
that makes sense.
When podcast like a big deal for it though,
you know like it's something I could just put on long flights.
I think that was the big deal for sure.
Like boom,
here's the deal man.
Long flight
for sure.
You could definitely knock out a few episodes and you know,
you know your home.
So that's how it has definitely a big deal for me on long flights.
Yeah,
it's a game changer.
Right?
Especially you either get in like a really cool conversation.
I said one time I was listening to one,
like some war shit.
I don't know how I even got up on that shit,
but I listened to a war podcast and they were talking about the nuclear wars and
all that type of shit and that type of shit you don't listen to
if you eat an edible before a flight
[inaudible] or something like that,
you're like,
aw man,
my anxiety's going through the roof edibles.
But I learned that I can't take them on flights.
Last time it took an attaboy almost pushed the button.
Really?
I don't know why.
I just kept looking at them,
but I didn't want to push this.
I don't know what's going to happen,
but my heart's beating fast.
We sweat to push.
The last flight
took it on was was a flight to Australia and that's our fucking long flight.
You have the anxiety and then you're like,
you're like,
I'm going to come down.
I just will be all right,
and then they're like,
ah,
there's 11 more hours.
You're like,
oh shit.
Like it just,
it just fucks.
Yeah.
Why would you do that to yourself?
I can't even take drugs in public.
It gets too fucked up for me.
Like I have to just be alone.
I know you're not supposed to do drugs alone,
but that's probably it.
That's time doing
embarrass myself in front of people.
I like doing like long flights like that.
I try to break them up.
Like if I go to Australia,
I tried to come here for a few days.
They ain't go to Hawaii for a few days.
Didn't go to Australia,
but oh,
that's the way to do it then just break it up.
But the um,
I mean Xanax.
Yeah.
Wake up.
Are you there?
Are you on any time you want any time?
Be like,
shit,
that's a good plan.
You don't know those that you're a big mommy
try.
That's right.
You came in talking about butt plug because
the new guy into the cool guy club,
uncle Terry,
his butt plug,
because
he is nasty.
[inaudible] have to pick anything.
You know,
in this day and age,
you know,
it's hard to be yourself.
You know what I'm saying?
[inaudible] out there now.
Have you seen him?
Do you watch our show?
I seen him like in real life.
I hadn't really seen last time you guys had like a,
a retro one.
Like there's multiple [inaudible] life is like real job.
I start to wonder what his personal life about that.
You would do this on that.
You could just do this like no one,
no one ever finds out.
Do you tell people what you like?
What do you do?
I wonder that all the clubs when you go did somebody at the bank today,
Terri
[inaudible] you got some problems too.
You get what I'm saying?
But
Zilla
by the way,
we didn't even,
I didn't even tell you this.
I wish I got head from throws Zillow.
Zillow came to my Dallas show and I just saw it on Twitter.
She was like,
I'm finally here.
And she took a picture and post it and I was like,
hi throat Zillow.
But she didn't,
you know,
I didn't get the show on a bummer.
Yeah.
Throw Zillow,
follow her on snapchat.
Yeah.
That's a good follower.
[inaudible] has great content,
man.
I always loved the,
uh,
the juxtaposition of her,
her skills.
And then she was like,
I'm going to get gas.
[inaudible] she'd take the whole family to the buffet.
Zilla as again,
somebody very comfortable with herself.
I a recent,
when you guys
and knew it had left me in tears,
the one this motherfucking and brought a damn rat called God.
That shit had me crying,
man.
Yeah,
that shit was crazy.
We don't like to talk about McDaniels.
That motherfucker had a Derecho
and it was San Francisco,
which was the most intriguing part of it.
That would have thought that would've been like,
yeah,
be like an intro for my next album was
fucking me.
Yeah,
definitely have an uncle with dead laying dialect right there.
for sure.
And then there's also some psycho who's bringing in fucking Ted raccoons.
I mean,
yeah,
we equal and every Thanksgiving really like of the Midwest.
Yeah.
No
wait.
Are you for real?
I don't know.
My aunt does it,
but it's cool
off.
Still be in his mouth.
[inaudible]
I guess it's,
it's,
it's a hood delicacy,
coon hunting.
Shine a light.
Cause they kind of
just affect the way the motherfucker be on the table though.
You definitely live my dream and that you fucking made it as a rapper.
I think that's the coolest thing ever.
It took a long time.
I never learned how to rap.
Yeah.
You always say that that was,
yeah,
it was the weirdest shit.
What?
I mean,
I tell her if write the story probably a thousand times,
but the first time ever rap was kindergarten.
I said kindergarten,
I was in kindergarten,
we was showing tale,
but I didn't know and I didn't have nothing to show or pill,
so I just like fuck it.
And I just had a little rap in front of the class.
And then once I finished the class,
like Kraft and stood up and did the teacher was all like,
you know,
she,
she really encouraged it a lot.
Anytime we would have like some type of school play or some shit like rap,
rap always putting me in shit to make me rap.
So I guess that they started with that.
And then I remember after that getting the confidence from the school I rat from
my cousin was like an older cousin,
you know,
he lists a lot of rap music and shit.
So I wrapped the him and then the look on his face after I was finished,
she was like,
you didn't write that.
Like he just had a weird,
oh this,
I got some here.
So
Brian,
like what,
what,
what was your kindergarten?
Yeah.
But it was always,
you know,
oh,
you got to think that's like the 80 so it was that hope.
My name is dede place to be so fresh is lead,
let's say close to what I say every day like that,
you know,
it wasn't like no real lyrical miracle Shit.
You know?
That's how I would right now I bought a book,
I bought a book
when I was in like fifth grade,
maybe fourth grade.
And it was like,
uh,
explain hip hop.
Oh wait,
one of those.
Yeah.
And it was like,
it had like run DMC on it and it was like death means,
you know,
it's like all the slayer.
Oh yeah.
And I was like,
oh.
And I would like sit with it and be like,
you don't even know what that means.
And that's a weird,
because every place,
like in America,
like everybody has like slang,
but it could be like words that mean different shit.
But it's the same word in different places to him.
Yeah.
So that's pretty weird.
What's the,
what's the latest Detroit Slang?
I mean,
to be honest with you,
I live in Detroit my whole life,
but I've been in the suburbs probably like the last 10 years.
I'm sorry.
I don't know what the fuck is going on in Detroit.
Every time I pop up it's like a new big ass under Armour store somewhere like
going down.
Yeah.
[inaudible] kind of blowing up though.
I go down there,
I go downtown,
I'd go down to the city and it was like,
what the fuck is going on?
Cause I have a studio still in the city so I have to go work.
Y'all going in June.
I hope you're right.
I shouldn't be all right.
But I definitely will be starting to work,
but I should be home.
Um,
yeah,
last time I was there.
Oh,
so I was there like a year ago.
They were like all these different,
uh,
pro like,
you know,
building a new stadium.
A lot of nights as hotels now,
which is weird.
Like I'm talking about a place they used to be like,
crank didn't heavens are no hotels.
No,
it's weird,
right?
Like with fucking free breakfast and shit and hipsters with fucking car hardhats
on and look at worst,
the biggest trip choice airport.
Well only because like especially let's say 10 like within the last 10 years
people were always talking about like the economic downturn of Detroit,
right.
Things like falling apart and houses abandoned all this stuff and you're like
Detroit's in rough shape.
And then it would be,
it's a big uh,
Delta connection point.
Yeah.
So you'd land there and you'd be like,
I don't know,
you'd expect like for some reason in your head like,
oh it's going to be like Fallujah in here or something like that.
Like the Cleveland Air Force
and then you go in and there's like that psychedelic
and then there's like a,
a lady on the,
on the speakers going like,
what's going on in the day?
You're like,
oh shit,
this is kind of cool.
It would be like the coolest airport experience and that he's a comic.
That's all you do airport.
So I remember I have been a two nights I spent in Detroit airport or just amping
stranded.
There are a couple of times because of weather and then they shuttle you out to
that fucking sad ass hotel like a mile.
Yeah.
You're like,
this is fucking terrible.
But the right there,
Paul was there a big party and I had some good food there.
Yeah.
There's like a total resurgence now.
I know I have to go see it.
I haven't heard so long and really change it
as much as you know.
Uh,
have I lived there my whole life,
but the past 10 years I can say I don't really know what the fuck
I stay in the suburbs.
I stay in my house.
I don't really go to CD that much,
but when I do I always see some shit.
Like what the fuck?
You ain't got avocado toast.
He's kind of resent it though in a way.
When something like that's coming through,
we've been fucked up for so long.
I'm just happy to see like basically put a future on the kids and shit.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
It would be,
you know,
like Detroit was always a big city,
but we would never treat it like one in that sense.
You know what I mean?
Like it's not like a tourist location.
Motherfucker.
I'm going to go to Detroit right
there and do some cool shit.
That's cool.
So is it like you're happy for it?
Yeah.
That's cool.
Um,
so yeah,
we were talking right before you came on that like your videos are so dope.
Huh?
Thank you.
I like I say,
I can't really take too much credit for that.
I don't know man.
You're,
you're definitely greenlighting Asian and like,
so are you a big as part of the come from the fact like that you're a movie
cinema fan or something or no,
no,
no.
I don't,
I don't even have the attention span to watch movies and shit.
Really Real.
What?
I play a lot of video games.
What is like the video process like for like when you have a song and you're
like,
all right,
we need to make a video.
Do people start pitching you really like I make music and music and I never
really think of what to make a video for anything like that.
So you leave my managers that might be like this one,
this one,
this one really.
And then when I decide what song will do and then we'll just get a whole bunch
of treatments in,
you know,
and then you just go over to treatments and figure out which one is cool and
usually work like that.
How the fuck do you become a rapper?
Like people are like,
how do you become a comedian?
And we go,
okay,
you just go to the comedy club and looking at the same shit.
I feel like it's,
I feel like it's more special.
Crazy
career I would say.
I mean what,
what it was like,
cause I was,
I came in that era,
you know,
hip hop was like this.
Dang.
Have you had to have an image?
She had to have a look like I've,
I've been in so many,
like labeled me this early and it was like,
the music is dope,
but you don't have to look what the fuck dumb dirty motherfucker from Detroit
braids and a missing tooth.
And they was like,
this is the day like 50 cent and everybody had muscles.
Is that 50 cent story true?
Yeah.
I live with Tony Y'all for like a year.
You live with Tony.
So many stories with that
in New York and La.
Got It.
Hold on.
So for people that don't know,
I know that,
uh,
I guess,
did that come from like g unit was we're signing you,
is that from living with Tony?
It's a long story.
Like I said in the beginning,
what I would do,
I would,
I would just literally I had a connection at Rockafella records.
Hey,
on rd or that like my music.
So I would take these 12 hour greyhound trips to New York,
way before cell phones,
all that shit,
calling on pay phones and this and that.
How surfing [inaudible] stay with and go out and you know,
and I will record these mix tapes.
You are a comedian was making mix tapes in the weekend and go back home and then
I will make,
I had so many mixed tapes from doing that,
but then I ended up going to jail and when I was locked up for that year,
I was locked up for like a year when I was locked up,
my brother would put my music on the Internet.
And what happened was by the time I got out of jail,
I already had like a name on blogs and shit.
Like hip hop blogs were like post my music and shit.
So when I got to jail like Oh,
that's what I'm gonna do now.
Isn't that a trip in and of itself that you get out of jail and you're like,
oh shit.
People like,
yeah,
but it still wasn't like a,
like it wasn't gonna get me a record deal.
Tension.
Okay.
So,
like I say,
I had to take it back to it,
some standup comedian type shit and I would go to open mics to sign your name on
the list and you know,
type shit.
You know what I'm saying?
So,
and then I started to make,
because I knew it didn't matter for me to have my music all over these blogs and
no one in my city knew who the fuck I was.
So it had to go around and go east Oakland mice and get my name known in the
city because at the end of the day,
like at a record company reached back up like who's cracking in the city or
what's,
you know,
even though I got my music around on these blogs and shit,
nobody knew who the fuck I am.
It's not going to add up.
So I got my name out and then I ended up meeting the manager and for meeting
that manager,
you know,
stuff just started rolling,
snowballing from there of Shit Dude.
Okay.
So where,
where does a not at 28 off situation fit in that is that I used to go record in
the studio in New York,
in Queens,
which was um,
but this is all on your own?
Like trying to put it,
like I say,
the ANR that I met,
he would take me to the studio,
I make my mixed tapes and that was in Queens.
And when that studio,
when I was,
I guess I was in jail or whatever password,
when that studio shut down,
the engineer from there I started working for [inaudible] and then one day they
came to Detroit and the engineer just was calling me like the week,
like you were in the deed,
whatever.
But then when you get some weed and we yell,
Y'all Blah Blah Blah,
I read it even we pray and talk to each other in years type shit.
And then I just showed up to the hotel room,
you know,
brought him weed or whatever.
And then he was like,
oh,
you got some,
you know,
he knew me from making music,
so he's like,
you got some new shit.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm like,
Oh shit.
Yeah I do.
I just put a video out and I show my video and he just,
he didn't let me leave after that shit.
Really believe
he won't even let me go pack clothes.
So I'm going to go grab some clothes like no,
you with me and threw me out the next day and I was with him for like a year.
No Shit.
Okay then what
happens?
Cause I've heard this and I purposely didn't want to uh,
look up details.
What I heard was that like you're going to sign with g unit and then 50 cent.
It's back to what you were saying was like,
oh,
but your,
your looks not right.
Yeah.
Back in those days I wear like super tight.
Ask any juries.
Yeah,
well call them tiny pants.
Shout out the bass.
God,
you know what I'm saying?
Skinny jeans I can even pull up.
So they'll just be like,
way down here.
I'm a hoe ass is hanging out,
colorful draws and shit.
But,
uh,
I remember we did a show in Connecticut somewhere like that,
but they had a show and then I just worried,
he's like super tight white and skinny jeans
and he got all these gangsters around.
But before that he'd been told me like,
you know,
you need to look more threatening
these jeans that had like dollar signs on the back pockets.
They were huge.
Yeah,
just look terrible.
I remember,
I remember when I was wearing skinny jeans and shit,
I was getting girls and stuff,
you know,
like I'll go to the shows now,
can meet girls and shit.
But then he gave me his big ass jeans wearing the with like vans or like chucks
and shit.
I just looked like a gangbanger.
I just looked like I was up to no good.
I will get no girls.
Then it's like fuck that.
I'm going to have to what I know and like this,
but does the look thing is that does 50 actually it'd be like,
look man,
you ain't got the look.
He loved the music.
He loved a lot of my music.
But then like I say,
he told me to chill out.
Just you know,
you're gonna get your turn,
just,
you know.
But then eventually I was like,
fuck that shit.
I'm doing what I want to do.
End of the day.
I still,
I'm 37 years old.
Yeah I could,
I had to be like late twenties at that time I was already,
I was already battered and bruised at that time already touched,
he could press about none of the shit.
Right.
So he's so hilarious on Instagram.
Is Instagram actually who he is as a person.
That's actually how it used though.
So I remember we had a show and then I had these tight white pants and then he
just,
I don't know,
he just freaked out and was like,
you got this motherfucker around me.
Motherfuckers gonna think we gained [inaudible] about to get beat up man.
It got like that where if I was like fuck.
So then after that was over,
I knew in my head it was over like I got to go home.
So I think I lied to you and told him I had to show us up like yeah,
show in California,
which I did like at a fat beats for like $20 or some shit.
But it all worked out man.
It all worked out.
Yeah,
no,
the videos I,
we were just,
we were watching some videos like,
but yeah,
I guess the video thing,
um,
because I remember,
I remember when I'm in a funny,
came out and like,
Joe didn't,
Jonah Hill's right.
It's such a,
like,
it's always shit like that.
That's pretty lucky for me and I'll take,
you know,
I'm really blessed stuff like that.
He just
really liked the song and reached out to do a video for it.
Sounds amazing.
And he wanted to really,
it was before he shot the movie that he just did it his way of like tests and
the cameras and like that was a way to practice before he started shooting the
movie.
It's a great,
it's a great view of what the songs really 19 thank you man.
Yeah.
Um,
is that,
do you go into songwriting?
Like it's your style to like think of,
you know,
do you just write down like a,
and like all this is a title or did you just like label whatever it comes out
of?
You mean for so long I went with the strategy of whatever kind of my head.
I write it down and type shit,
like how we're wrapping my head all the time.
So like,
I'm pretty sure like you guys think of a joke,
he's like,
when we go write it down like you and your fucking bit and you bought the
fucking calls always hallway in a punchline.
Pop up in my fucking head.
Yeah.
Uh,
or the shower.
I've other ride on a fucking shower
and I'll tell him,
I said,
if I'm remember it like fuck.
I mean you never will.
So I did that for so long that I think I'm kind of like blessed to be able to
just write punchlines and shit on the spot.
Yup.
Types it.
So did you hear that beat first?
The Aina funny beat is crazy.
See,
that's the thing.
My producer Paul White,
he sends me so many fucking beats that hour.
I'm probably write a song right now if a beat that was me four years ago.
It's no telling how long I had that beat before I even started writing to it,
which is a good thing because you get so many ideas to listen to a piece of
music for so long and then a lot of times I have so many beats from a mill stuff
I just put beets on.
I listened to him and I will let stuff just happen on his own more so than be
like,
I'm going to sit here and write a rap.
I'm like,
I'm a write her song or yeah,
we'll come up with this concept.
No,
I would just be like put beats on and every now and then I might have a couple
of bars for this beat.
I might come up with a hook for this,
but I might come up and eventually it just starts painting it's own picture for
yourself.
I don't really go into the try to force it no more.
However,
I just wanted to ask about like this.
They'll give us such a distinct performing voice.
Did you always perform with that,
like,
you know,
no.
It took a long time for me to actually find a boys to find that voice.
Yeah.
I probably do like three mix tapes before I even started rapping like that.
Really?
Yeah.
I think Adderall,
you get a lot of credit.
I really like the beginning stages of Adderall and he'd be like,
fuck.
I feel like a super human.
Like I'm really like,
like I can see farther.
I can hear her laugh.
Like I really thought like I would really bought into the whole thing of like
I'm a better person with type shit.
Yeah.
It makes me work better.
It's big like that,
but he has,
it's a downfall to that.
Children don't get me wrong,
it makes you a fucking cycle
a lot.
I like bipolar patients because Adderall.
Oh really?
Yeah.
You just have these like
mood swing when you take it for so long.
Yeah.
You had these crazy like mood swings,
which I can't really like is like you'd be like,
something's fucked up,
but you know what I'm saying?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
I've never done it.
You do every day?
No,
I uh,
no,
no.
I liked downers.
I like,
I don't like me.
I like downers.
Like I want to do Xanax hot.
That brings me
down
Downer soon
after uppers.
Great.
That's a real party man right there.
If you're like yeah,
after the other shit.
Yeah.
Um,
all right,
so there's,
this guy was trying to give you a heads up yet.
This guy is,
I mean he's too cool for the cool guy club so we have to put them in his own
club.
He's his own cloud light just to give you like a little like test or what we do.
Oh
God.
So this is hard rock nick and um,
smoked like a magician.
Yes.
I just know he know some magic trick
or we were thinking,
Geez,
this mother fucker though.
Just the photo day.
Do some shit.
Something's going to disappear in a second.
It's been a while,
hasn't it?
Alright.
I decided to make a video since I'm stuck on the four oh five on my way to Santa
Monica.
I think the topic of this video will be something a little more personal.
Let's talk about why bad ass.
Good looking rich guys don't have girlfriends like me.
Why is it that girls will date a guy that has half of my wallet?
Half my Dick,
half my car,
half my bank,
half my personality,
half my looks half my wardrobe,
half my sexual prowess.
But they'll pass up a guy like me who's Fon.
Good looking,
interesting,
edgy,
educated.
And once again I'll ask you to do
eyelashes and eyebrows.
Yeah,
he's a bad bitch right here.
He's just a bad,
bad,
bad.
Oh,
got jewelry.
I love the hearing
is a Babin.
Let's talk about that.
As you get older,
you understand,
it's actually a compliment.
Why a guy like me is single and then I looked around and guys that have big ass
bellies or you know by all their shoes at Kmart,
girlfriends.
So why don't we have no friends or why don't I
what I'm saying,
man,
this is,
I bet you this motherfucker know how to fight to
fucking jail.
Sit next to that.
Make me never commit crimes again.
You run into in the county jail and shit like that.
Yeah.
Talking all kinds of crazy talking about bitches and shit,
motherfucker.
I know you're a bad bitch.
I know you ain't.
Come on man.
If you look too good and you got it going on,
women are mother fuck in Hayden.
They all like to see you ball.
They don't like to see you ball.
They don't like to see you succeed.
They don't like you looking better than that.
They don't want you being desirable because that's gonna make them vulnerable to
you leaving their bitch ass.
I would think he has a fucking room.
One of those who cock ring.
Yeah,
I would.
You are
my biggest period,
but I can fight and I could do magic too because he was a bad bitch.
Yeah,
just old code following.
Absolutely book and I bet you can belly dance like do that shit.
No.
What though?
You've got a point here because he's got that appeal that prince had.
Let's be honest,
when you break it down,
it was a small motherfucker.
He was short.
He wore heels and it was a bad on that weird,
weird beard shit to write weird fucking beards.
They just loved him.
Loved him.
Yup.
I mean and they probably have the same net worth.
Yes.
Easily.
Yeah,
I know cause he just to,
he too much of the bad bitch like bitch don't want to be around.
That's right.
Another bad day.
How much time?
I hear it in the,
how much do you think this guy's worth?
Just eyeballing the jewelry.
The like look at his style.
What would you guess?
I don't think he worked at like office depot or some shit.
Well guess again,
he is worth $350 million.
That's what he says.
Not with that Polo shirt.
Like I don't think this is a real polo polo shirt,
but this what might be fake.
That's a big pole.
You're right.
That's a big fucking Colorado motherfucker.
He definitely went through this shirt a few times.
Yes,
you're right.
You could add a bar fight and as we hang up a good point.
This logo,
the Polo logo,
this is about,
I've been times normally small,
big ones like that.
They do.
Oh motherfuck the horse and the men are like morphing into one thing,
right?
Well,
no separation between horse and man.
Don't forget that.
Would you like nick probably has access to stuff that they don't release it.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
You're right.
It's probably like a special pickup truck.
Yes.
I mean that's one of his,
he has like
bid slash scary mother fucker all in one.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
He goes to Gold's gym to got six houses,
12 cars.
He just got personal chef.
He goes smack his lips.
I ain't got a job,
but no man doing all this deal.
What would on my hands like?
Well,
so yeah,
we haven't,
we haven't
watched this one.
Yeah.
Why don't you go ahead and show us this video with just one shot.
I get this question a,
okay.
Okay.
What do I wear?
Pink.
Okay,
so much.
I wear pink because I like pink pussies.
Oh,
you know,
like inside.
I like to actually spread the Pussy Lips.
All Ben while I'm cocking missionary.
Yeah,
that.
And the other reason I like pink or wear pink is because if you look at all the
richest men in the world,
which I'm one of,
I have 20 million in the bank.
No bullshit.
Suck on my fucking testes.
Um,
all the richest men in the world where paint.
Yeah.
50 cent.
True.
Wears pink.
Tom Cruise.
Where's pain?
All right,
Simon.
Rex fucking where?
St Contracts.
So that's what it is,
man.
20 million in the bank and fucking growing.
I hate over it.
Um,
you don't need to hear it when you're this good looking baby.
Yeah.
There you go.
Now to be on his bad bits team,
but Nah,
hell no.
I come because I know this is a mother fucker.
You don't want to run into on the streets,
but part to the story.
What does motherfucking like five.
Oh
yeah.
Do you think you bring up his,
uh,
bio,
his bio that he wrote because it kind of will inform it,
but he liked over six feet.
I'm terrified.
Yeah.
Now hold on.
He said he's worth 20 million,
but before he said 75 million didn't.
Oh my God.
They cleared there.
Uh,
you just had it,
the sheet.
Oh yeah,
there he is.
He wrote his own bio.
So born in Vegas,
grew up in men wholesale.
How are you though?
And he grabbed him.
Yeah.
It's kind of hard to see that one.
I mean he has some selfies we might be able to see,
but see,
look worth a good 350 million,
three 59 account in the house I live in.
I prefer eating pussy from the back almost 300 pounds,
Danny.
But I carry it like I'm to 10 all right.
Damn.
But he also shops at Bristol Farms Gelson's or whole foods market.
You can,
you should consider rewriting your bio and everyone in the poor business that he
wanted to.
Yup,
that's right.
Yeah.
That is the resume.
The resume right there is in Brentwood too.
He puts the location.
I tried to be on the same man,
but the more and more I look at his ass when I left eyebrow Combo may want to
put the shit out of him,
but I don't think I can take them.
Say,
I don't think I can take
you don't want none man.
Definitely don't.
Oh No,
no,
no.
I hate him.
I rock nick man.
Well that's probably,
that's about it was taking one of his six houses.
Yeah.
So you're saying if you were in jail at this guy.
Oh Man,
I should keep my mouth closed.
Keep it shut.
Yeah.
Cause you don't know what he's capable of.
No.
You know what he capable of being in this motherfucker.
I know he did some shit.
You to put in some work.
No prob.
Oh my God.
That is,
oh go check it out.
You see that like Cuban link chain on the outside?
I want so 40th is coming up
and you're a rapper.
Will you please tell my wife that I should get one of those for my 40th?
It's not an ethical
did not yet.
How to not get a chance.
No,
you don't.
You don't need it.
Stop it.
Yeah.
I'm no team like I don't have jewelry.
I'm not dead.
I have um,
you have France.
I did until I got my teeth fixed.
Amazing teeth look great.
Amazing.
I'm now,
what did you do?
30 $30,000 in a year off work.
Wait,
but uh,
it looks great.
What happened to the front?
Oh,
I can't fit 'em no more.
Really?
Yeah.
So I've got,
I'm either going to take the diamonds out and do something else with them or I
don't know how much we're front.
Can you tell us that I spent 10,000 on one and it's been maybe 7,500 on another
one.
So you're looking at about a hundred grand in your mouth.
Was it then I had another one that's been like 15000.0 shit.
Yeah.
My last one I spent the most of.
So should I get those you think?
Yeah,
my 40th.
but so you what having with me,
you know,
trying to be so cool an excel,
my teeth was already fucked up anyway,
but me wearing the grills,
it accelerated it.
And what it was was me wearing the grills on like flights and shit and I will
fall asleep in the saliva would just give,
you know,
get caught up in there.
And I saying that's pretty much like acid for your feet.
Oh,
I was really like a few steps away from dentures.
Really.
My Shit was,
I had to get bone graft and audit.
No Way.
That's why I had to take so much time off really to get all of that fixed.
I did not know that.
Yeah.
So this,
that's actually a better case for buying the chain,
I guess.
But people see you with me.
I'm from the hood.
So cannibis snatch a grill.
I know was robbing you fucking a fucking,
that's just disgusting.
Yeah,
that's,
you want me to pull my shit out of my mouth like this shit.
Like
Shane will get snapped Nash that well,
what I understand like,
all right,
why don't we set a like a sailing,
a price limit to that.
What's a reasonable amount I should spend on his chain for his 40th birthday?
I mean,
what I know for a good chain.
And you want a piece too.
I know.
I just do the chest,
the chain and just to change
at least by his 40th birthday.
So let's go special.
Safe.
Feel Cuban link to,
they're expensive and you want something heavy.
You don't want no hollow as bullish.
That's right.
He's got like 15 k,
15 years when we got to get a new sponsor,
you know?
Good.
Good up for like five,
5,000 yeah.
Okay.
Calluses.
Listen,
I'm moon.
I would say,
um,
I wouldn't say it all on my Eric.
Okay.
But often.
All right.
I ain't got it.
They got it.
They got show me some love.
Yeah.
All right,
well that's okay.
Fine for a shitty man.
I swear they treat you like shit.
Well,
you know what?
The big thing about that fucks with everybody is that unless you're really in
the know,
you can get hustled so easily.
What will you tell him
now?
I know it's like
I never really got ripped off because I'm just so,
so cheap and some sense that I'm going to check this shit soon as I buy it from
you and if it's fucked up,
I'm coming to highlight you.
Every time I bought jewelry,
I'm pretty much went about it the sensible way,
which is the dominant way,
to be honest.
It's going to and be like,
look,
that's how much I got.
What are you going to do?
Fine.
It never let her,
cause then they always go,
oh that's right.
You never going to get what you really pay for it.
Not saying that's right.
Yeah.
Jewelry's just,
I dunno,
but if you don't do that,
it's almost like they're going to,
you can come to that motherfucker with the intention of spending a couple of
dollars and next thing you know you're like fuck you get your receipt.
Like fuck,
I just spent 20,000 [inaudible] yeah.
Well it's also like,
you know,
you,
you start looking at stuff and there's no mystery to it.
People just show you the baddest shit and people would be like,
that's what I really want.
They're like,
oh,
that's this month and then start telling you deals and shit.
Like it's really 50,000.
I'm gonna give it to you for that answer.
She really had an idea.
You're taking me out,
you know?
[inaudible]
you think you getting over type Shit,
you know,
mother fuckers.
Got You.
So it's a dirty game and jewelry.
I just don't,
you know,
you don't have to do,
I'm a hit up nick.
I'm no,
I'm asking.
That's nick
watches.
Like just wear like vintage watches.
That's cool.
This is my new,
I got a Domino's pizza Rolex.
You know people that have like a lipstick tickets,
people Domino's pizza,
Domino's pizza and you sell enough pizzas in the year.
The owner of dominoes get you a Rolex.
Somebody just,
you know some [inaudible].
Wow.
There's really a Domino's pizza.
That's awesome.
But you can't resell it because
every restaurant like Arby's is the most expensive one.
If you can find the Arby's Arby's cheaper than 50,000
like the resale value on numerous crazy 50 grand.
But here's what I actually from the nineties
Domino's pizza,
somebody sold a fuck load of pizzas.
They just gave it away to the trophy like that too.
My dumb ass
children,
I got so many dumb watches.
It don't make no sense.
Can inherit another one.
I love this.
I got on like the 90 Rolexes Lexus like biggie and Tupac would word and shit
like that.
Yeah.
That's cool.
Then I have like the Rolex Jay z rapped about on imaginary player with the real
Rolex diamonds and shit.
Like you got some nice watch and again,
like the old nineties Jacobs and stuff,
the early 2000 [inaudible] Jacob watches and stuff.
You have a car collector and that's it.
Uh,
what's like the,
alright,
cause what's the dumbest Shit you've bought?
Oh,
I have a lot of that shit close.
Really close was to like,
uh,
which I've stopped like I guess at this so long I'm just collecting shit and
buying stuff.
But I bought,
um,
so many dumb,
like one time I was in London as Selfridge and I bought this dumb ass,
like a Rick Owens,
like sleeping back Kate type of thing.
I can't even explain what it is.
It's a picture of it somewhere.
And um,
it's just a cake.
It looks like a sleeping bag with a stream.
The stream around your neck and it just grapes over you.
How much it was like $3,000
did motherfucker in my closet looking stupid.
What the fuck?
So yeah,
I don't like buying expensive clothes is definitely the dummies.
I think clubs is kind of even crazier in a way.
Cause I bought some expensive clothes.
Donald's money,
you went a little crazy and you had to return some of the,
it's almost crazier than jewelry in a way cause close,
close.
You get like a few whatever wearing.
If it's a picture on Instagram and it
can be timeless,
like a good jacket.
That's true.
Jack
definitely wasted a lot of money on high end,
like high as
I could find a picture of it.
I'll show you what he's making.
By the way.
There's this whole thing going on now about like some of the high end fashion
lines being accused of like blackface stuff.
Braces at Montclair this week
been like that man at the end of the day.
Have they been,
have they been doing stuff like that a long time?
I don't know.
I'm just not even familiar.
I just saw the stories.
I know debt in fashion world,
a lot of a lot of brands field at once.
It's popping in like urban communities.
That's the decline that they line so I can see what Gucci to me,
I think it was a planned situation after they did the dapper Dan thing.
They did the most Nigga shit they can do and they did some Nigga Shit,
you're going to just attack.
They already got the money from.
It's like Gucci has been revived so many times like it pops it then they fall
off in the project.
This was a way of saying y'all Nigga stop buying this shit right now so we can
get back to being,
you know,
cool.
And our audience,
because right now it's like an urban brand.
So you think though there is like some like almost conspiracy in a way.
Right?
I think that was,
I think that was purpose.
They did that.
I'm pretty,
I don't want black people to wear the clothes right now.
No Shit.
They had a nice five year run with us and now they're like hotel,
let us get back to being high in and then when we need y'all motherfuckers
again,
we will make some fucking all over print shit logos on it.
No fucking way.
Like the one thing that gets me out as like when you see these stories and
there'll be images,
uh,
with like something resembling,
you know,
black face,
there's no way,
but when they're like,
oh,
we just made that,
we're even thinking like that.
Like,
because a fashion house like that to approve of something I
really wanted,
that was the whole way of like,
chill out.
Y'All got Gucci Cause uh,
uh,
tip found the,
I guess he,
it was an older Montclair jacket and you're like,
is this real?
And it,
it definitely didn't know about this job.
And I know the Gucci,
it was a sweater,
right?
I'm going to,
Montclair really had like real,
like blackface,
but it was actually a designer in the 90s that was a black designer from Paris.
I can't think of his name right now,
but he actually used to do that too though.
So I in some sense,
I thought they was trying to like do a take on what he used to do in some sense,
but I don't know.
That's so crazy.
I mean Claire Jacket,
but then you guys can't see it,
but then swipe.
Yeah,
this is bad.
What is that?
And they're like,
it's just a do slides.
Literally.
That's what I feel like.
That's just,
that's his campaign.
Quite literally his pattern,
he says show the camera,
then they'll bring it up.
And then the jacket is the,
is this black?
It's like old timey Sutter and it looks like it looks like a minstrel shows,
minstrel show stuff that's so that it's very you to walk around and be like,
oh,
it's just my,
I'm a big fan of like early 19 hundreds night racist movies.
Yeah.
It's my favorite thing.
But and stuff and stuff like that don't really age will either.
So like motherfuckers [inaudible] it's just like,
it's so trendy for now.
You can't wear that jacket in five years.
You look stupid.
No,
of course not.
Where are you gonna wear that jacket right now?
So that's my thing.
I tried to now buy clothes with the,
with the thought of timelessness almost.
Yeah.
Now Shit from Amazon.
Like I used to high end shit.
I would like go to Bergdorf's and you know self rich or really is all about
going to like certain stores and certain places.
Like I go to New York,
I know what my shop,
I come out here,
I know I'm a shot,
you know I go to London,
I know miss shot but I ain't going to fucking shopping and Minnesota [inaudible]
get some shit in Vegas.
Might get some shit man.
Certain places.
That's when you go to New York is always the bird off and fucking Dover Street
on it.
Sure.
Yeah.
Can we talk about jail for a minute?
What about it?
Well we've been watching that show love hate Hayden cards.
Did you ever get on an inmate dating site?
Oh Man,
I was in a dating site.
Tell us everything you're dying to know.
A lucky motherfucker to get the opportunity to work registry and registry in
jail is like the best job you could possibly get.
What is it?
Registry is when people come in to get registered because only two people could
work the job.
So I got lucky.
I ended up getting a job through some rap shit too.
That's just a long story,
whatever really.
But I got the job working registry.
And what that means is when people come in to get registered,
you just,
the person down there helping the police,
you know,
if they tell you,
give them some Greens,
go get him something,
you know,
so that the kind of mother fucker that passed off to sandwiches and shit,
that police have to obviously be like this is a somebody who's not a problem.
So yeah.
So like any other inmate,
you know,
I would get letters from girls or whatever on the outside and stuff,
but it got to when I was like fuck this shit.
You know what I'm saying?
And what I would do is I would pass up the sale just to the female inmates to,
so I see one come in,
you can see are broken and battered.
You don't know what she going through.
You know what I'm saying?
Get the inmate number.
I will look on a slip and I would get the inmate number and then I'll write them
like,
yeah,
I was the guy passed you sandwiches.
You know what I'm saying?
I see your case.
I know what you're going through baby.
After like six months of this,
I was never getting mail on the outside.
I was only getting mail from other perfect,
a little freaky shit like shit.
I know her court date.
She come down and show me your titties or something through the bar.
I'd be going back to my steel like the best day of my life.
I don't know what the fuck is going on right now.
You know what I'm saying?
But a titty flash when you're
like fuck I'm watching girlfriends and shit everyday get horny up.
That shit.
That was like the real deal.
Like
I stopped [inaudible] go straight.
That is you would find out when her court date was.
You get to see her though.
She know when she coming down or you might get lost in to register it.
Come on.
You got to go down to the register area to go to court.
Most of the people in the county jail,
the people fighting cases,
they ain't really got the time yet.
So they do to go through the process basically held before you go on and let you
already got time and you're doing time there.
You can't do more than a year in the county jail so.
So yeah,
a couple of girls got time where they was in the county then you wouldn't see
them no more because they are not coming back down.
But we'll be writing each other a little freaky letters and shit.
It was a terrifying or was it like manageable?
Of course it's terrifying.
But once you get to jail and once you get used to this shit and I ain't gonna
lie man,
it's price.
Some of the funniest guy
you meet the funniest motherfuckers in the world.
The jail.
Hate to say it man.
Yeah it's been a good big
job with my personality.
I can't take it.
I can't,
I can't think the world would that experience.
You know what I'm saying?
What's the best part?
What did you like most about jail?
I ain't saying I liked anything about jail cause I would never want to go back.
Right.
But um,
it just was fun.
Motherfuck cause you gotta think at the end of the day you a grown as man but
you get in reduced back to a child level cause the motherfucking telling you
witness lead motherfucker tell him when to eat.
So all you do is act like a kid at that time.
You put it around acting like just silly as fuck.
Cause no like you're not getting high.
You're not.
But there's another thing too with me working registry,
you get access to the cigarettes.
So I was like the guy that sold the cigarettes in jail,
even though I didn't sell any cigarettes,
I shut that shit down.
I just smoked them.
Oh yes.
So I will use my cigarettes will give me leverage to do shit.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you have to sneak where you could smoke them to.
Is it like a demo because it was no cigarettes of and county.
I mean we're just,
you smoke after down like after 10:00 PM when they've cut all the lights on the
shit.
Everybody's smoking in the room.
Yeah.
And breed you have,
oh is it,
is it ventilated
once they lock you down?
No,
motherfuckers leaving out the bubble.
They ain't paying y'all no attention.
No Mode A.
Every now and then we get ready and get caught in.
What you do is it's,
it's terrible.
You take 'em baby powder and put it in the sock and you just beat the walls and
everywhere and you wake up in the morning and looking like a fucking cocaine
castle
boot up.
Yeah.
And Are you spray bleach and it gets rid of the lesion in baby powder.
So that was our air fresheners.
But so yeah,
so me,
I would have the cigarette,
so I'll just use cigarettes.
Like I could be wanting to take a nap,
but motherfuckers out there yelling too loud,
playing space.
I'm like,
I'll get y'all motherfuckers a cigarette to shut the fuck up.
You know what I'm saying?
Give him a cigarette.
They shit fuck up.
So I was like running shit because the cigarettes,
cigarettes man.
So it's 10 o'clock lights out.
The guards aren't around like is that one in the party?
Yeah.
You smoke a cigarette and take you out to sleep.
That's all.
He didn't talk shit to guys.
Are you?
Oh the funniest shit I've seen in jail was dead motherfuckers.
You could,
you can take a trash bag and put it over your toilet and like clones are the
water out and then you just yelled through the bowl and motherfuckers a year old
bet
cause my data to all other floors.
She like Dayton chatline of jail.
Really to me.
Bitch.
What's up?
What's going on with you?
What flow
is hilarious.
Yeah,
but you don't want to bunkie that does that.
You don't want to beat his mother fucking head.
You're trying to sleep,
motherfucker yelling.
How would you bunkie I had cool buggies to be honest,
the less buggy I head,
that motherfucker was on the first 48 he got killed
recipes.
Robert [inaudible] biome.
We got to a be one time cause some reason this motherfucker like bananas and
Shit.
You know what I'm saying?
You know you work here like registry and shit.
You get put an orange,
that's when you get a job.
You've got and got more access to food and like a normal inmate.
So it is fucker was steel like the whole shit's a banana,
the whole stocks and shit and just be in a bunker and just didn't know Dean
Banana,
banana and it has nothing that would annoy me.
He knows I get your potassium up I guess.
Yeah,
the Nigga would take a shit like right before lab down.
You know what I'm saying?
Like shitty banana smell is like,
the worst thing is sleep through is like,
man,
it's like I seen a yellow fuel my stuff then pass it off.
So yeah.
What do you like?
Dial it back with the fucking bananas man.
Yeah,
we got into it.
We almost had to handle the situation,
but yeah.
But then I remember I got out of jail and I was chilling,
watching fucking first 48 in this motherfucker.
Wow.
Oh,
I got older.
I was like,
you know,
he was the one that got murdered,
but damn did they uh,
did they,
uh,
it was it one of the episodes,
they caught somebody from there and he was the one getting charged with killing
him.
Thanks.
All right.
Can we got his bananas man,
now so you,
you're,
you're telling me that you have to take a shit.
So there's one toilet in the room with both of you.
Yeah.
Now how do you,
you get used to shitting and from the other guy,
but Dennis a pie.
You don't have to be sitting in that room.
Oh,
a day.
So if you,
if you're not locked down,
the rule is ain't nothing happening once we locked down.
So whatever you've got to do,
do that shit.
But can you drop down?
You gotta take a shit.
I'm out here watching TV somewhere.
You in the room taking a shit.
Okay,
so you guys kinda work it out like,
Hey,
get the fuck outta here.
I have to shit type shit.
Yeah.
And you have toilet paper.
I buy all that shit from commissary.
Okay.
You get it from the commissary,
you got you got you.
Okay.
And what kind of snacks did you have?
I know
I was the king of like,
yeah,
what,
what's the high value snacks with me?
I'm not really a sugar motherfucker like that anyway.
So with me when commissary you only can spend $100 like a week or some shit.
So I was more so to the sox draws tee shirt by mother fucker.
Damn near kill your whole hundred dollars or some shit.
Yeah,
sure.
So I always just bought new sites cause I didn't,
I'm not a motherfucking hair wash and tee shirts and shit.
Yeah.
You know that should just blame.
And I don't know.
So I just always stay new stock fresh.
So I was more so on that way.
May fresh stocks still feel good,
always kept.
And it's to the point where I would stack up so many like dirty socks and tee
shirts and draws.
Motherfuckers are taken from it.
I'd take them and wash them and wear them their selves.
It's it
disgusted,
but what were the big snacks there?
Oh motherfuckers like making,
oh well me,
I had a cool guy from southwest.
They may own burritos.
He would take it home.
That's when you take a bag of Doritos and shit and you crunch them up real fine
and you take like a plastic bag and you lay that out.
Then you put like the,
the the crust Doritos.
Then you chop up like slim jims and beef steaks and cheese sticks and at you and
you put it together and you roll it up like a Burrito.
Do you put it under the hot water?
You just let the house
water rather than it didn't close it all together so no shit was kind of
firearm.
That's kind of good.
Yeah.
I like,
is it Nacho cheese?
Doritos.
Cool ranch.
Okay,
that's good.
That's
another thing that God put me up on was what got me through a lot too.
You take a bag of like barbecue chips,
crunchy crunching up chips,
I don't know.
So they crunch up barbecue chips and you put boiled eggs in there and you shake
them up,
you shake them up.
It's like happy Easter.
[inaudible]
did you guys,
do you have access to booze when people sneak
county jail to do weird shit.
Toilet wine and I think the banana peels right or some shit.
Shit,
I had cigarettes.
I was cool.
You obviously know this is the home of the Cool Guy Club.
We found
you might appreciate this.
This is another voicemail.
Young lady posted that.
She was like,
I don't know why I gave my number to this guy,
but he,
he,
he gave her a call and left a voicemail.
This is the day after she gave him the number.
Gotcha.
Go ahead.
What's a
I text you last night.
She never responded back.
Um,
if you didn't want me to have your number
Dominguez Hill,
he might.
You want to be little young,
dumb mind.
Debraj oh,
she got a little rinky dink.
Minimum wage job at Marshall.
Thank you to bomb and avian a firecracker wearing wigs like you use some 90 year
old lady with no hair.
Whoa mean.
I thought she had a nice face and body,
but beyond that,
there's so many chicks in San Diego with that and I got plenty of them.
San Diego
about to be chasing you around.
I mean,
unless you're mentally retarded or something.
Normally you want somebody calls or texted you that you gave your number to
respond back.
I guess you too retarded to realize that.
I'm going to just go ahead and delete your number.
Yeah,
go for it.
Dude.
I love when people tell you I'm going to delete your number.
I just do it
as
women say,
men are trash.
By the way.
This kind of lift that after I texted you yesterday,
that's it.
This is the call.
You texted her.
All right.
She didn't respond back and then you leave that.
Well,
yeah,
that's a cool guys do though.
Jeans,
school,
he too cool for me.
Yeah,
there's a cool guy.
He's very cool.
But there's guys like that,
uh,
they keep calling and calling and they don't get the picture.
They don't get the message that you're not interested.
Yeah.
I think this is what's so cool about this guy is that I think this is called
number one.
Yeah,
he was,
he just shot.
He just gave up.
He gave up.
He definitely fuck
older.
He debt Marshall sounds like he's at least 30,
like this is a kind of excusable when you're 19,
20.
But I'm like at work before.
Ah,
do some shit like
that.
He's done.
He's very dumb.
Very dominant man.
Right?
Yeah,
he's very,
I like also played his cards right.
He's dogging her job,
but he was at her job,
you know what I mean?
Close animal wage jobs where you shot bid.
Yeah.
That's a good point.
Um,
so,
oh,
what's the,
um,
what do we want to show?
Oh,
you big ODB fan.
Of course.
Yeah.
Check out.
Uh,
we got,
we got a little,
I've never seen this clip,
but I wanted to play it.
Oh Shit.
This is when he just got out of jail
or asshole.
I liked her because it was Tinier in the pussy hole.
Yes or no.
If told me it was like tiny as a quitter.
So when I,
when I get the feeling of licking peppermint patty,
it was nasty.
He looks crazy.
That's crazy.
It,
but this was,
I feel like,
you know,
this was a different ODB then what?
We fell in love with it.
Right.
This time in his life.
Eat Abouti got McGirt.
Yeah.
The Trick Daddy,
either booty guy booty game
for that one.
That's what that,
don't get me wrong when a security camera on you.
Yeah.
You gotta
gotta gotta go for the Muffler,
I guess.
Yeah.
Yeah,
he is.
Yeah.
I mean,
I'm not like some look good there.
You're right.
Okay.
Let me ask you this.
I just just occurred to me.
Sure.
Would you rather for my 40th birthday?
Yep.
Uh,
get me like the Cuban link diamond chain.
Spend 15,
$20,000 or just eat my scrum.
Ma'Am,
you have to think about this.
Yes.
I'm going to go,
I'm going to go on the gold chain.
Jeez.
Am Our kids won't go to college.
It's fine.
$20,000.
Yes.
A tier.
And you only spend 10.
What'd you eat?
Has grown.
I mean,
what the fuck?
He's so hairy.
Nasty.
No,
I wouldn't need your scrum.
Not for your birthday.
It's pretty good.
Hot Score.
Five he ever had a lady look,
you're right.
Yes.
Which
is amazing.
Really.
You're not a hairy guy.
I'm guessing you're not.
Do you shower up before?
She does not do wipes.
What do white dude wives.
Oh yeah,
you got to break on to do wipes.
Okay.
Will you dude wipe it for me Tom?
I will definitely do that.
I'll tell you though.
I'll get waxed.
I'll get laser treated down there and here's law two.
I'll do a little like rose pedal thing.
The bedroom be on the changing table with my legs up.
You got to see what I see though.
Now these ladies that have eaten your Scram,
I mean fun.
This is not marriage material.
I'm assuming these are,
these are ladies that you're serious with.
My wife definitely go eat the booty.
Yeah.
Course.
What do you mean?
I mean,
come on.
He's like,
I'm Danny Brown.
Yeah,
that's true.
Can you just go,
go for it.
Why am I just go for it?
You shouldn't do it.
No,
you should do it.
Alright.
ODB was into it.
No,
I know,
but he's different.
He's special.
He's more talented.
Crazy man.
He is crazy shit.
I think this is,
did he have like a lot of children and the child support was the issue for his
money and stuff.
Welfare.
Steel.
Yeah.
Oh that was an amazing one too.
That was like real Odi.
That was the best that was,
that was his cribs,
right?
No,
it was MTV.
It was just like when MTV used to do like MTV news reports and they said like
this fucking nerd and he went in a limousine yet pick pickup is boost up.
Yeah.
And he was like,
Hey,
he was drinking and it was hilarious cause white,
but whatever.
That's free money.
Right.
Did what parts I go turn down free money.
Damn ODB.
And he left the welfare office in a limo and he was,
yes,
go crazy.
Best Black.
Excellent.
Ed is fine for me as a kid.
See it.
That looks like that is what I went to aspire to that.
That's my hero.
That is black.
Excellent is fine.
Oh,
DB was one of a kind man.
Yeah.
One of a kind.
Um,
big baby.
Jesus.
Probably my phone
every day.
Every day.
Like my probably three times a day.
I drank so much that the prisoners was actually training old,
dirty cello.
Huh?
Shit
man.
This mother fucker was crazy man.
Yeah.
It was a fucking genius though.
That was the thing about it.
Anybody.
I think everybody that's so talented in something,
right.
Dave just lead,
lose other shifts in the process of becoming at time and Dick because he
definitely was a crazy motherfucker,
man.
He's got a lot of people used to try to compare me to old dirty bastard and shit
a lot and stuff and I just be like,
y'all crazy Maca.
Never compare it.
No Shit like
that.
Well he was also like,
um,
I don't think,
like you said,
you never learned wrap me.
He would just,
I mean I'm from the interviews and things I've seen,
they would just take him in the studio,
but yeah,
I remembered risen Jesus,
his cousins.
Right.
So those are,
he was the little cove.
So those are your big,
yeah.
So even just looking up to him,
like he would say they owe raps and most of his songs like just oh reps,
they wrote his kids and shit.
A lot of his reps was like just old wraps.
He was just randomly saying shit.
Are you,
were you,
uh,
is there any producer that you are like,
ah man,
I would love to do a record with someone.
I think most of them I've worked with already some sense,
but I guess,
no,
I don't,
I want to say cause I'm kind of,
well I can't really talk about it all right of shit.
But yeah,
I guess I would probably,
I would love to work with Reza.
I want you to do something with Suede.
The remix.
God,
swear to,
I love it.
I love him.
I love city.
I love it.
Shit.
I don't know why I feel like you guys would vibe.
No,
I definitely,
I could,
I can get on some of his shit.
But I think um,
me and music is starting to,
music is starting to be,
so I'm kind of the best way.
Like it's starting to be so computerized.
I know how to say it.
Like it seems just so easy to make type shit.
So I'm trying to do a more traditional back to making 30 fucking 40 year old rap
now.
You know what I'm saying?
I can't make this shit.
The kids make no more.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm starting to go back and take a more traditional approach.
Even with recording it.
Like I don't even really want to record in protools and shit.
The more I want to still have that old Warren tape sound and shit like that.
So just doing everything that I grew up listening to,
which is like Wu Tang knives and stuff like that.
So trying to make music like they made music,
my deep stuff like that.
So I'm going back to doing stuff like that.
No,
I was just,
I was just learning the eye cause I remember when,
you know,
sometimes you remember the moment,
but you don't realize the historical impact of it.
I remember when illmatic came out,
but then watching that there was like this documentary about it.
I didn't realize how crazy that album was because he just don't eat 19.
That's why.
Um,
and also who,
who decided to like,
cause you forget like I just remember buying the album,
listening to it,
but you forget that at the time he's,
it's being produced by like every top producer in the game.
And that was the first time that happened.
Nobody really,
most of the time you'll get a budget.
You will just have one producer or you know,
but like Q tip,
but all got premier,
all the top people and they've Seeked him out.
Put Him.
That's crazy.
But yeah,
I fucking prodigy man,
like 19 years old and saying this shit,
he's saying,
that's why I don't never give any excuse when people talk about,
but he's young.
He's a kid.
Like especially in this day and age are making music where,
you know,
rappers probably dominated by teenagers right now.
Sure.
But now it's just 19 motherfucker ain't no excuse now.
No excuse.
I'm making dope music.
So just cause you're young don't mean you have the right to mix bullshit.
So young
man.
Yeah.
Um,
what's going on with,
with,
with uh,
this pronoun thing.
What does this,
is this another wait,
what?
Oh,
the Starbucks stuff?
Yeah.
Oh,
that's,
that's something that Christina,
this is a while.
Oh.
Oh yeah.
It put it up.
There's these pins now.
Uh,
I believe the employees,
the hey,
uh,
oh,
they were their program.
You can wear your,
do you know about this one,
Danny?
That's a little bit too much,
man.
See Jesse,
you see this?
That's only American man.
We take shit too serious.
Hey,
um,
what's your name?
What's your preferred pronouns?
They,
them,
theirs.
He,
him,
his,
she,
her,
hers.
Like little yesterday
I was watching a motherfucker uhmm a dog jumping contest.
Y'All seen his shit.
And I thought to myself like,
who cares if your dog jump hired and his mother fuckers to this shit?
So it was a dog agility contest.
I know.
I'm an only motherfucker that shit yesterday.
And I'm in my hotel room.
Like,
what the fuck is only in America?
Where am I going to cook?
I'll be like,
my dog can jump higher than yours.
Let's see,
I need a motherfuckers.
Did it and then they televise.
It is a fucking connotation where everybody bringing their dogs out.
Like my dog jumped higher.
No,
no dog.
Yeah.
This is definitely a symptom.
That's what you shared about when life is too easy,
so high,
these dogs can jump and then it's like,
I felt so bad for the dog because I'm looking at,
you can see the owners.
They got these real stern and phases.
They take initiative serious like,
God damn,
man,
I ain't doing fucking obstacle courses and shit.
Come on,
man.
Yeah,
we're having technical difficulty.
What's Your Pronoun?
Press pause.
We were just blacked out.
Oh,
did we get here?
It was okay.
Our computers went down for him.
It.
Oh,
oh,
we're,
yeah,
we're back.
All right.
That was easy.
Yeah,
it does seem like a privileged fucking problem.
I was just reading on Twitter about weight.
Privilege.
What's that?
It's a mouth
feel shitty or need to check your weight.
Check your white privilege.
Did you know that because you're a quote normal weighted that it's a privilege
and you need to check it now you chose.
If you're not overweight,
people that are overweight,
like don't have the same advantages that you take for granted.
Oh Wow.
You know,
and check your privilege under 600.
You're this asshole walking around.
Yeah.
That's only in America.
Nobody in Jeremy thinks about shit like that.
Nah,
they just eat these sausages in prayers.
Pull apart the date it is Americans bring,
uh,
like we have a really interesting way of making things like that are not issues
issues.
I got in front of me at West so we'll kind of cool to be fed.
Yes.
And like a certain place like Texas as cool to be fair.
Yeah.
I love this place.
It's good.
I think that's where I want to retire.
Like Texas,
like they'd like fat motherfucker.
Yeah.
See I'm in the Strip club in lemon pepper wings.
No,
it's like throwing a bone pitches.
Just come to him.
He'd be skinny.
They like to fuck around with you.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Yes.
Hang with this.
And they think you pour.
If you skinny,
I was going to ask you to,
in the Midwest,
do you guys have this pronoun stuff or
they don't?
That's not a thing.
This is just a West Cape beat up for being gay in Michigan.
We are very close.
That's why I can't go nowhere else.
That's why I love it,
man.
And keep you in check.
Yeah.
You feel like it's more,
it's more indicative of the rest of the country.
Like this is kind of how normal people are in the Midwest.
Not How la is definitely ain't on no fucking Kito Diet.
Eat Kale and being gluten free and shit.
Motherfuckers ordering Domino's and shit.
We get lost in a bubble out here in New York.
It's just too expensive.
I live like a king where I'm from.
I know.
That's the way to do it,
man.
So fuck it.
No.
Okay,
so you take a plastic bag,
can't take some Doritos
plastic,
chop up some cheese with beef and cheese sticks until it,
that's the key.
The beef and the cheese,
put it under some hot water.
It's good for a minute.
You got to make it the authentic way to,
I'm not letting you skip it.
My mother fucking Michael,
I just pretty much knew what was in it.
He used to kill it to kill cigarette in the Burrito for big shit.
You living your best life.
So he would,
but he would get something in a trade for that
shit.
He was pretty much like steps.
That's a big deal.
Stamps and letter envelopes.
So there's gotta be dudes in jail who are just,
you know,
not savvy,
not with it.
And then all of nothing.
But I mean like,
like never like they're the ones who are like,
I need stamps,
I need socks,
I need shirts,
but they don't got shit.
I ain't got shit and they don't get shit if they don't get shit
a lot.
That makes you just more and more fucking,
I guess bummed out.
You be the one fucking mopping my floor for a cigarette and shit.
Like
how are these people,
these inmates dating people on the motherfuckers in prison
for a long time.
That's when you can buy a TV and a CD players and shit like that where I'm at in
county jail.
You Ain't getting shit.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
What'd you only do it for a year?
So that's Kinda,
I did eight months.
That's still,
that's long.
No,
what am I friends did?
He did two weeks at the towers,
twin towers downtown,
which is horrible because they forgot about him.
Oh yeah.
No.
To have a loss of a system monitor.
Five had my DJ.
We did.
We had went,
he had some old like warrants or some shit and we went to China for a day,
like a dummy like I am.
We went to China for a day and came right back home.
When we landed in New York,
the police locked his ass.
Didn't record for like a month.
Whoa.
It got lost in the system to have,
I didn't have my managers and shit on it and they got him out.
Whoa.
Yeah.
That's what he did when he got lost in the system though.
That's horrible.
It is horrible.
Um,
yeah,
it looks so,
one of my favorite types of videos up,
we played them before.
I don't know if you like,
these are not,
this is when somebody is still under the effects of like an anesthesia.
They're coming out of it,
you know,
but they're saying crazy shit that they normally don't say.
And this patient was like when I drink.
Yeah,
exactly.
So she is uh,
you know,
still under the effects,
but this is all,
this is a good one,
right?
The problem.
I heard what you said.
Every time I eat and I ran shit.
Oh Shit.
Ever.
She is a very respectful in front of me.
Like this.
Nausea,
zippy,
common down ocean water.
I have to make it black excellence.
Yes.
Okay.
I got to be a talker anyway.
Oh Wow.
She said black excellence.
Yeah.
I wonder you still passing gas act Kate.
Oh,
Shit.
Clear on the way.
I'm mark.
Go home.
My ass burning off.
Okay.
My ass.
Holborn oh my gosh.
You're just not by saw in Greece.
He know.
I'm quick.
The third we know.
Go home.
Okay.
I want some water.
Take this topic.
No.
Sankey besides math,
you gotta have something that's going to hold my asshole.
She's hilarious.
Standup.
Sit right there.
I know,
right?
This poor woman,
she's coming out.
Dj.
I got to see her 15 minutes,
man.
Right.
I love it.
Oh my God.
You know what is?
Oh yeah.
She's funny.
She's amazing.
I'll bring you one
egg it in
June,
but it's real good.
But since you don't have asshole
probably
eating.
Really?
Yeah,
you can see it.
Yeah.
That is a man that anesthesia port nausea and she'll have like no,
uh,
no record of this.
I know,
I know.
That's the most fucked up thing,
but I hate that shit too.
Like,
um,
when I drink sometime I black out some time,
but be conscious.
Okay.
Yeah.
It's not cool at all.
Dot.
I have a blackout in a long time and then motherfuckers been telling me he was
doing shit.
Like the last time I blew it,
I blacked out.
I fucking him,
I punched the lamp.
Oh No.
My fingers I'll curb now.
I woke up in my hotel room in his blood.
Everywhere is glass.
Everywhere is throw up everywhere and I don't know what the fuck just happened.
You know what I'm saying is when you wake up,
you see in this shit and I was like,
fuck,
I need to get another drink.
Like you got blue glass and throw up.
Like,
I mean,
I don't know how to stop this.
Like why don't you come down from his moment?
You got to realize what fucked up shit you did.
So I'm just trying to keep it going.
Yeah.
What did I say last night?
Did I do anything?
That's the
moment then when you go like such a parent,
I man,
I remember like,
well the one of the last ones that I did was like years ago,
but I was,
I had this job out here in la and uh,
everybody from the office got together at this ball.
I remember it there.
And Yeah,
you weren't,
they're with me.
Was this your birthday?
No,
no,
no.
When you jumped rope and the on that,
that was different times.
So before we were dating we started dating.
Yeah.
But similar,
the guy for me here,
before that,
before we started dating,
I was at working at this job at an entertainment company and we went out and I
just,
all I remember was,
well,
I remember nothing.
I remember like the,
before the blackout.
So then I,
my friend was like,
man,
buddy was gathered around,
everyone was gathered around and you were holding court,
like telling the story and people were laughing and you were just like almost
performing to them.
Right.
And he goes and you were super fucked up.
It goes in the middle of the story.
You just projecting,
tell vomit,
hey goes,
they,
you know,
after you spit your like,
like try to get it out,
you go spit and then you kind of lean stood back up and you kept telling your
story and everybody was like,
we're out of here man.
I was like mortified.
It was friends,
but it was also people from work.
We weren't good.
So that was Saturday night.
So then Monday morning you go,
I would go in to work was like you are.
Yeah.
Well we can only be comedians and rappers.
I mean you just,
what the fuck are you going to do?
You kind of get a pass
for it.
People take your piece.
Definitely.
If you're,
if you're performing doing that shit,
everyone's like,
that's cool.
It's like another story.
Yeah.
Cause I can't really,
I don't know.
I can't really have to like have a little something to go on stage.
Like I get worried about a whole bunch of people just staring at me type shit.
Sure.
So I'd like to have a few drinks before going on stage,
but a few drinks into turning to me being drunk as hell.
And I do always worry when I wake up the next day of saying crazy shit cause
I've done it so many times where like I definitely a habitual line stepper but I
get drunk.
I was getting a kick out of like pushing people buttons and Shit.
Yeah.
That's the fun part of it.
And as doing shit that you wouldn't be doing sober type shit.
So and I don't like that because that's like you're turned into another person.
Yeah.
What are you drinking?
I drink tequila
that she makes sure
because I'd use it,
drink a lot of Hennessy coming up and they'll just give you so much heartburn
and the browns the next day,
the browns,
some next level shit.
You know what I'm saying?
So
it's hot,
but Tequila doesn't give you hot browns.
Yeah.
You just dripping mud
frown.
Todd.
Can I tell you this morning I had my
first official short of 2019.
I can see,
here's the deal man.
I had men as shit.
We flew to Africa.
I sharted on the way,
but that's because I had three tacos.
That's stupid idea.
But it was a,
it wasn't liquid.
Sharpe this morning was liquid.
Like I farted and like liquid came out of my flat hall.
Yeah.
And then I had diarrhea.
Is that what happened?
Is that what you had with your Hennessy?
There you go.
Some more of a morning.
I had the worst is Molly if people didn't know if you take,
that's why when you go to those festival tolerates you go to the porter potties.
Yeah.
Do motherfuckers is just,
they just spraying compost.
It just makes you go instantly.
And I remember,
um,
I had a show,
I opened up a,
a childish Gambino at Central Park.
Wow.
I did a little more,
oh,
that's crazy,
man.
What's it like?
Remember dude,
what's it like to do in that though?
Central Park.
That's crazy.
But that's on the resume.
Took Molly.
I just remember being on stage and just having an hour long conversation with
myself like you're about to shit on yourself.
I was saying to myself like,
all right,
this is going to happen.
Cause he just started like I still got 45 minutes of this shit.
He Pekin you know what I'm saying?
He looking out the curtains,
you know what I'm saying?
I let his plate and start thinking about like maybe Donald got some shorts or
something funny like how maybe I can shit,
but all right.
Oh my sax is white.
I don't like these long shorts,
but I thought
I could maybe beat the case man shit.
And he's shorts.
But I may make a long story short.
I'll be able to very agonizing.
Terrible set for me.
But I think I,
I think it was a good step for the crowd.
Yeah,
they're no good.
I'll walk you right.
That dude needs to shift everything.
You're under adversity like you play your best shells like when I'm sick or when
I really don't even feel like doing it.
That's when I always had my best sets.
Yeah.
But I remember Springton from the mother fucking stage to the Porta potty and
when I got sick and I wasn't a nurse,
somebody sprayed that mother fucker up.
All you're looking for.
But after that it was a party.
You're gonna say man,
cause you find that one,
you're sick or you have diarrhea.
Doesn't your body kind of shut it down when you perform?
Like you're,
the adrenaline kicks in and like your body knows like,
oh we can't shit right now.
Real sick in Europe.
I don't know novices and I've had like maybe three weeks of shows left.
Oh I had to perform like every other night.
I'm talking about where to be a day of me.
Just like any bid rep and for some reason man and you're a man,
they don't got the heat.
Right.
Like you know what I'm saying?
It's always cold as fuck in a hotel rooms.
Oh yeah.
No matter how high you could do to try wonder why they all be drinking tea in
London and shit cause you motherfuckers don't,
Ya.
He'd know
more of yourself in that bid.
So I couldn't get healthy for shit.
I should've probably went to a hospital.
But you know when you're black you're like fuck that shit.
I ain't got no insurance basically.
I ain't going no motherfucker fucking how's Goodwin?
Helsinki?
I don't know what the fuck going on in Finland.
So I rode it out like a gene and got myself back home.
You know what I'm saying?
But yeah,
pick sick on stage such as or here's the worst.
I was sick as fuck and playing one of my shows.
Somebody just having too much fun,
just doused me with like a full glass of water.
Normal Shit,
like ramp shows,
you know the water on each other.
But mother Fucker,
I'm damn and got pneumonia.
Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
So yeah,
I cut that show.
I think it's because they have old heating hold shit dude.
Fucking old dumb vents in the floor or maybe the stupid,
you know?
Yeah.
The whining looks like Europe stope except for that,
that kind of shit.
And then like the oil,
we also get spoiled for space.
Like you go to someone's apartment,
you're like,
the fuck you live here,
Tony.
The smartest thing for me was the ice situation.
Anytime you order to get you four ice cubes,
like mother fucker filled his mother fucking cup.
I was,
I went,
I was at a place and I still remember in Italy where I was like,
I ordered like a coke.
I was like ice.
And the guy's like,
hey.
Then
he told another guy,
he was like,
just do once.
And then that guy left and they're like,
and then fuck with this shit.
Minutes later.
I'm like,
hey man.
They're like,
he's going to get it.
I'm like,
he's going to get it from you in the next door in a restaurant.
And then you know,
20 minutes later the Duke came back.
He was like,
we have,
we couldn't find any ice.
No Nero's don't like guys.
And also everything has a fucking door,
right?
They have 500 doors inside of the house.
You got to put two doors on the matter and then a door here and the door
door,
door.
It's terrible.
Yeah,
I love it out there.
But you had the limousine business are not American
like I like when those,
what does that show?
When they would,
they would move member,
not house hunters international and they were like,
we live in Nashville and a 7,000 square foot and we're moving our six kids to
Belgium and then they'd be like,
here's the apartment is 350 square feet.
Good luck.
And the kitchen is in the toilet.
You have to cook your shit in the toilet cook here.
You can also iron right next to the fridge has an iron on it.
They're like,
no,
I can't take it.
I want to be Fed Little Cup
of ice
[inaudible] 78
I'll like be be honest here in a hotel room
to be hot chicken.
So we always cold.
So where am I met?
I want to think I'm at a warm climate.
You know that fucking psycho.
You met in the hall.
We can tee shirt on.
That dude literally will turn heat off in the winter and just live in the cold.
That's white people.
Shit.
You know who else it is though?
It's not just white people shit.
It's serial killer shit.
Motherfucking muffling Arctic Arctic blast.
And these motherfuckers was still out.
Shit.
Like one day you'll see somebody like that
Michigan game,
like you know,
shirtless
out of your fucking mind.
I feel the same way when I see maniacs jogging and it's pouring rain here in la.
I'm like really like a Douche bag asshole.
You know what I'm saying?
Motherfucker.
He knows I'm up.
I'm going to want to work out anyway.
Are you trying to tell me it's 20 degrees below zero.
You just go and run.
I'm doing my thing.
Can you think that bad mother
fucker we opened with you think he's a out there doing that shit.
You know what the cool facial hair?
No.
Hell no man.
Mother fucker.
He wanted them mother fuckers that bought one of those.
Um,
and then he goes have a cadaver.
You're jerking off.
Oh Danny.
Whereas any,
any big show,
any showed you want to plug anything?
I got a lot of stuff going on.
I mean I just really finished my new album stuff.
Just I've done so much,
it's still so fresh.
I can't really talk about stuff.
Which kinda sucks.
I guess next time I'll come back,
but for a,
you've got to come back,
please come back.
Bring the Cape Prime your $3,000.
Kill that mother fucker.
I'll give it to the dog.
That motherfucker need to get some use cause at least someone's person wearing
that shit to shows.
Man.
It's the dumbest
person.
Devaney we'll bring it back.
I can't forget that.
Oh actually in the dumbest part I have like another one is not a Rick Owens
though.
You got another Cape actually got another book and it's the um,
what is from oak?
This one oak,
but it's like a,
like a cloak.
Did you ever wear it and it has a hood or yeah,
I performing his shit.
Oh really?
You're so golf kind.
I like it.
No,
I had a phase of that kind of dark.
Yeah.
I like that.
Cool.
At the time I was like,
I'm more to just be uncomfortable man.
Yeah.
Like especially like the last time I wear skinny jeans,
my digs a shrill and I've been working with so love,
I've been wearing jogging pants and shit.
How many blue man,
I just don't think I could wear skinny jeans no more.
This must be a life,
a phase.
Cause I'm all into the company.
It's comfy pants.
I can't believe I was flying in jeans
or like just 15 years.
I just did it recently.
Trying to be cool,
trying to arrive cool and shit.
But I'm always a pajama.
Like I got these pants.
I'm going to send you these pants.
Right?
I'll tell you as soon as your,
first of all hilarious.
You're a phenomenal guests.
Amazing music.
You,
if you guys want the the website,
at least we'll keep people updated.
Right?
Uh,
barely keep them Twitter.
Nothing here to let her.
All right.
Much Danny Brown eggs.
Danny eggs,
brown eggs at Twitter,
Instagram.
Oh my shit is X.
Danny x Brand X.
Oh yeah,
twitch.
I'm mostly twitching,
so.
All right,
well there it is.
Um,
thank you so much for coming.
[inaudible] had a blast.
Finally get to kick it with the moms.
Yeah.
Not the jeans.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm tight.
You Shit.
Are you kidding me?
We're going to fill this up and I like that.
All of us.
Sorry.
Garth Brooks.
My dream.
Garth Brooks dark.
Garth Brooks,
my dream.
Dark,
dark Brooks.
Whew.
Dark blue.
My drink.
Let's get dark.
Dark,
dark roast.
Let's get dark roast my dream.
Dark,
dark road.
I like that arthrosis.
Dark roast.
My dream.
Let's get dark roast.
Dark,
dark roast.
Let's get dark roast my dream.
Dark,
dark road.
I like that.
My
God.